e
morning everyone and welcome to the
Health and Human Services committee uh
Health and Human Services and L Affairs
Committee of the New Hampshire house uh
we have several bills on the docket this
morning and throughout the today for
hearings and executive session but
before we get to any of that I'd like
Allegiance PL ALG to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
the uh the first bill this
and shman is it's more like a Monday for
me today than a
recognize get to the right
page representative Edwards the prime
sponsor
uh thank you Mr chair um I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham uh District 31 uh I'm based
in Auburn um I'm here to introduce HB
1347 um and uh upfront I want to point
out that uh the this committee has my
apologies uh this bill is a little bit
of an embarrassment to me this comes
across as very
xenophobic and it wasn't intended that
way and because uh it I of of what I
just said I I I think I owe you an
explanation back in September I think it
was when we were supposed to be
submitting bills I was under a double
whammy I had my leg in a cast and nonwe
bearing cast and I was taking some pain
medication at the same time I was
recovering from a a dog bite infection
and I was a little delusional from the
drugs I was taken from that and so when
I submitted this bill uh I submitted it
with a different intent and I don't
think it was drafted in consistent with
my intent I think the the attorney um
made an assumption I believe and this
turned into being a focus on just the
resettlement program which was never my
intent I I I'm I'm fairly familiar with
the uh Refugee resettlement program and
I'm generally comfortable with it I I
don't think our Afghan visitors were
screened properly and and there's
probably a little bit of a of a a
problem in that community that we don't
know about yet but but in general I'm
okay with the settlement Refugee
resettlement program and I'm not after
it what what what I had intended to do
though was
recognizing that uh we have an A a wave
of immigrants coming across our
border a great millions of them who are
not going through ports of Entry many of
them are uh called Goda ways that escape
uh the efforts to catch them in the
interior and even those that uh get in
uh and often cases they they they lie
and they claim Asylum uh for political
persecution and they're given a court
date that's five years in
advance now I'm not a lawyer so I don't
know what to call that category of
people who enter our country under
illegal means who get a temporary
permission slip to stay in the country
or those who got away who Who hide in
the shadows of our society I don't know
what to call those people um uh in in a
legal way that would be put into the
bill but if you'll accept that there's
some term or terms that would describe
that sort of illegal uh uh set of people
who were here with
without uh respect for our laws really
um then then you'll understand what I'm
I'm trying to do is with that group of
people I'm saying if you come into New
Hampshire and you start to try to Avail
yourself of DHHS resources I mean the
resettlement program is just but one
example and and somehow it you know when
when this came back to me I was I was so
out of it I never noticed that it's it
was so narrowly focused my intent was to
take all of the DHHS programs of which
there are probably 20 or more that
provide some kind of support for the
social determinant of care housing food
you know
Medicaid uh and the like and I wanted to
I wanted to say to our citizens and
those who are actually legal guests of
our country um you have first priority
on these scarce resources that we put
into
DHHS and that this other category of
folks who are here in in properly um uh
or under the
radar if they show up at a DHHS
eligibility
site I I would want to make sure
that they did not start to
receive the benefits that we're spending
taxpayer money on until we have fully
satisfied the needs of our own
citizens uh and uh and that that was
what I intended to do with this bill um
because I was a bad legislator in
September and October that that's not
what has shown up here at your your
doorstep and again I apologize for that
uh you can either kill this bill or
amend this bill but I I I at least want
to tell my constituents that I cared
about protecting taxpayer money to
ensure that our citizens get first
priority for the services that they're
paying for and that those that have
entered the nation
illegally um uh are not first in line in
New York City I understand stand they're
about to hand out
$10,000 uh each uh debit cards to have
those who are here illegally receive
great benefit they're getting the
reparations that that our
African-American Community has been
asking for for 50 years they're they're
just being given
$10,000 and I don't want that to happen
in New Hampshire I don't want anything
like that to happen I want to be pure
from um from a program dramatic
perspective that we prioritize New
Hampshire citizens now at the end of the
day if there's still some money
available and there's some and there's
still a need out
there I I I I guess I'd be kind of open
to that but I I just want to make sure
that uh our people are know that they're
first and that we respect the fact that
it's their money and it's their state
and that we're trying to protect it and
and help them out and so uh uh I guess
in summary I really don't like this bill
U but I I I do think it's a platform for
discussion and potentially uh a really
smart amendment that would protect our
citizens um but um with that I'll I'll
I'll take questions if there are any
representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Edwards for
taking my question question um I really
appreciate your explanation of why the
bill is as it is and it's the Bill's
horrible as it is yeah and it didn't
meet your intentions I'm glad to hear
that
um so you spoke about people coming
across the border illegally and I would
agree that it is a huge problem and that
have no legal
documentation but
is it your understanding as it is mine
that there are many many people who have
some form of legal status but are not
citizens so they may be in the middle of
a process of applying for um
Asylum um or they may be um awaiting a
hearing on that or they may have
temporary protected status because of
some kind of um disaster so that would
you agree that that there are it's not a
black and white situation of legal and
illegal but there are all kinds of
people with various
statuses would you agree with
that I I I I would shift the black and
white nature of the of where we're what
we're talking about I um illegal legal
is is is not the right black and white
definition okay um what uh would be more
appropriate would would be to to find
that other category where that we can
Define this other couple of categories
one category I would hope we could all
agree on uh would be uh the category
that avoided points of Entry that
eluded Federal um intervention and
documentation those people who are the
Goda ways who are are free floaters in
the society where we have no real
knowledge of them there there is that
category and it's not
insignificant that is the group that I
would think that we could all agree on
probably ought not to be uh equally in
line with the New Hampshire citizen so
if if if that's one point of
demarcation what's the next area and
this is a good policy conver ation I
think you've you've hit on it is that
there is a group of people who um did uh
get um processed by the federal
government that did uh
claim political
Asylum that were under the federal laws
given a hearing date those hearing dates
from what I understand some of them are
as far out into the future as 2032
that may that's probably an exception
and not the rule but these hearing dates
are four five years out right year year
now just just to like wrap up the
thought there because there's another
piece to this and that is that it I
think it is widely and universally known
in in that illegal immigrant crowd that
uh the permission slip into the United
States is to falsely claim political
Asylum
when they're here for economic
reasons because they
lie they are given a court hearing to
check their political Asylum if in that
court hearing it's found that they did
they're not here for political
persecution they're really here for
economic reasons they are not eligible
to be in the United States and that they
are subject to deportation right and so
we have this massive abuse of the
federal system and and there exists a
category that I think Common Sense
people know is being grossly
abused as a matter of policy though do
we want to try to carve out those that
do have a federal permission slip to
stay for a hearing from those who were
clearly undocumented thoroughly and and
I think that's probably a category that
this committee would not uh want to
reduce the priority for them I I I and I
and I that might be fair but this other
category that's clearly here in an
undocumented status intentionally I
think we we don't want to be um putting
them equally in line with New Hampshire
citizens I that's a long answer I hope
it was thorough and and comprehensive or
comprehendable well follow up thank you
um I think I got it um so given that
this bill does not really address the
issue that you're concerned about um
what would you think about the
possibility of us itl in this bill and
in the
future creating some kind of
conversation for the for the legislature
for the State of New Hampshire about
immigration and its effect on New
Hampshire I think that could be done in
the form of a caucus it could be done in
for in the form of a study committee um
but where a bipartisan group of
legislators actually addressed the way
that New Hampshire is being addressed by
immigration the um great um gifts that
it's given us the problems that it's
caused how to move forward in the future
in terms of how we want to um position
ourselves in terms of um
both being a place that attracts
immigrants um for our Workforce and
um you know addresses problems um that
you're probably um more aware of than I
am um but what would you think of doing
away with this bill and creating some
kind of format for addressing the bigger
issue so so you you bring up two issues
and so I'll start with the the one where
we can agree to agree I think it's
always a good idea when there's a
special problem that's
emerging uh that uh a caucus of some
kind or a group of legislators get
together to increase awareness of the
problem and and you know and bring in
outside subject matter experts to help
inform us so that we we do some smart
things hopefully in the future so I'm
I'm all in favor of the second part of
what you said in terms of the
disposition I of this particular bill it
it's now in the hands of the committee
uh I uh if you ited it because it's just
a sloppy piece of work uh and that's on
that's on me I I apologize again but if
you think that this is a legitimate
issue uh and that uh it could be amended
then this is a platform at least to keep
it the the the uh the the policy alive
and hopefully enough to get it over to
the Senate because I think uh the the
the issue is is getting to be very ripe
it's getting to be timely if we kill
this bill I don't know that there's
another vehicle until January of next
year and and we could be in a completely
different situation in January so
whatever the committee does I respect
the decision I I personally would prefer
to see U an amendment than um killing it
but representative
wber thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question just as a
preliminary thing there's always an ad
hoc committee appointed by the chair of
this committee to study anything that is
within the purview of this committee but
my question
is uh because your preferences for
drafting an
amendment um I note that even after some
clarity and some thought you the prime
sponsor
are having difficulty articulating to us
how we would draft for the benefit of
DHHS the category of people that you're
looking for because if I understanding
correctly first of all they're people
with no documentation whatsoever and
those people don't get benefits secondly
there is a category that you are
concerned about out were the people who
lied and got a court
date how would you have us draft an
amendment that would
properly uh instruct
DHHS how to weed out those people who
had lied and gotten papers versus those
people who were genuine and had gotten
papers because on the face of it on
paper to me they look like just the same
thing so how would you distinguish and
how would we draft
that okay so uh I'm there's some Le
there is some legal terminology that
would be required that I don't really
know that may already exist and so I
would uh I I tried during the budget
process to bring this up but there were
280 other things literally in hb2 that
so I didn't find out about this the way
I wanted to but what the perception I
got is that this is a very uncomfortable
subject for
DHHS and I had a little bit of
difficulty finding somebody who would
engage me in a direct
thorough transparent way to help me
figure out what these definitions might
be I didn't have the time at the time um
but um
so so I would need to rely to your
question on how would I go about
drafting it I would need to rely on some
legal experts to help come up with these
definitions of these
categories and and then I I I think with
the proper definitions of the categories
I there is language in here that isn't
so bad that could be tweaked Maybe to
say that uh New Hampshire citizens get
the priority and these other categories
get a lesser priority or or no priority
uh so I don't I if if the committee had
time it had the patience it had the
interest I think um an amendment could
be drafted but it's that's really truly
up to the discretion of the chair in the
committee follow up so as a followup to
what you just said can you understand
understand why it might be uncomfortable
for people in the
department to have to be asked to figure
out a way to be charged with determining
as between two people who have exactly
the same
documentation which of those people
obtained that
documentation legally and honestly and
which person obtained that documentation
fraudulently how on Earth would they be
able to tell and is it possible that
that's why we don't have those legal
distinctions yes there's fraud if you
obtain the documents by fraud but that's
a whole different inquiry from what DHHS
does so so your first question is can I
understand DHHS is reluctance and and
the answer to that is yes because I'm
very empathetic and sensitive so yes I
can understand their reluctance um your
your your second part you you've created
a distinction that I have not you you
you you have uh said that I would like a
category that distinguishes between
those who are awaiting their court
hearing in an ethical way because they
truly are victims of political uh uh
persecution versus those who have lied
to obtain it I I have never even
suggested that I don't think that's even
possible for the Department to do that I
I drew a line back where it's earlier to
say um uh those that that have no no
documentations and you've you've made an
assertion that's probably true because I
I trust your knowledge and and judgment
that if they have no documentation they
get no benefits I that that is an
assertion that I would like to to be
believe is true but I'm not uh um 100%
confident in
that thank you and my apologies if I
misunderstood what I thought you were
hearing how could you understand this
it's a really bad Bill right now that's
my fault well it was it was the
conversation but I I I certainly am on
the side of people who want to continue
a conversation I I don't think this is
the vehicle but thank you representative
Seth King and then representative Kofa
thank you thank you Mr CH and thank you
uh representative Edwards for taking
questions uh given we know two things um
number one
that there will always be a need for New
Hampshire residents and United States
citizens and two that the current system
of refugee resettlements the immigration
system is completely broken I would
argue weaponized in many ways
given those two things um would you be
open to the idea that state funds just
should not be uh given for assistance to
non United States citizens period and
then you take away all of the problems
we have with distinction and who's you
know finagled the system and who's lied
you just get rid of that whole thing and
just stay straight up if you're not a
United States citizen you don't get
direct uh state State funds assistance
how do you feel about that thank you
okay so so I'm going to say that
personally how I feel about it is that
um I I I think that that may be um too
too broad an effort to protect New
Hampshire citizens I I I do think that
as badly as everything's being managed
there's a legitimate value in the
refugee resettlement program I I don't
care for the way it's being been done
but I think it's a it's a it's a valid
program uh at its core and I would not
want to
exclude those people um without hearing
testimony on why they should be excluded
and I've not heard that the other
category of people that are awaiting a
disposition of their political Asylum
claim
I'm I'm less patient with that category
because I believe the fraud is so
widespread that that I think as a matter
of policy we might we might want to
carve them out to say that they should
not be uh on equal footing with New
Hampshire
citizens um but then in this third
category of those with no documentation
I I I I think they're they're right for
us to um legislate that they do not
receive New Hampshire benefits does that
answer your question all right thank you
represent representative kofalt and then
representative
palazov thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking that question the um so
to that last Point really are you aware
of are you aware of any circumstances
where somebody who has no documentation
whatsoever is receiving State assistance
so me know I I I I I live with my dogs
in Auburn I'm not involved in uh DHHS
internal eligibility and seeing the
specific example so so no uh and even if
it hasn't happened yet my concern is
that the there is nothing stopping the
wave of people coming across the border
nothing stopping it really so if it
hasn't happened yet it's I think it's
just a matter of time before we start to
see the uh the impact in New Hampshire
inevitable representative Paz off and
then representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so my understanding of your
intention is that if somebody have
Federal
documentation uh he or she should still
get services but if they don't have any
documentation they shouldn't but my
question would be somewhere in the
middle for example we have a federal
system uh to figure out uh whose claim
is uh illegitimate but it's multi-step
process uh for example uh somebody is
claiming political Asylum or marriage
with US citizen and then Officer says uh
denies uh uh thinks that it's not
legitimate but then the person can
appeal in the court and then there's a
second appeal so uh it's like several
steps before the person is put into
removal uh so what would be your
preference like uh is it like first fail
uh in interview with Federal Officer
should trigger the consolation of DS
services or is it just
removal uh I I do not think New
Hampshire should be in the business of
second guessing uh what should be um uh
an established federal policy on once
they get a hearing date they enter into
a stage of adjudication and they have an
appeals process uh that's appropriate to
that and so so my my trigger for your
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also my
apologies to the committee and also to
the prime sponsor for my T can get to
the meeting somewhat late and looking at
this I understand um representative
Edwards that you chair the division 3
finance committee which has oversight of
the budget for the Department of Health
Human Services could you share with us
how many dollars from the state F
treasury go into this program not
federal dollars that flow into the state
that get reallocated but actual State
dollars that we actually take out of
state taxpayers to fund this
program uh I don't have an auditable
number to give you um uh I I you use the
word singular Word program and I just
want to make sure that if you're
thinking I'm talking just about the
resettle program I've I've I've made it
clear that I'm not you know that was
that's a drafting error in my opinion
I'm talking about the the 20 or so
programs that are all over
DHHS that deal with providing uh social
determinants of care the the basic life
support stuff food Transportation
housing clothing you know all those all
those social determinant care it's a
defined term but um uh
I as far as how much money is getting
spent on on those
things General funds if we spent upwards
to a billion dollars a year on the
collective of that prog those programs I
wouldn't be surprised I I think if I
were to leave you with a number today
I'd put it more like a half a billion
dollars a year on um various social
determinants of care programs of General
funds our our total budget I think is
about 3.2 billion a year and that
includes Federal money of which the
federal money is actually slightly
larger than the general fund
contribution follow up thank you Mr
chairman also thank you for taking the
question again represent Edwards in
regards to the amount of money we're
talking about is there some way that we
can break it apart because there are
many dollars that we spend on State
citizens that are actually residents of
the state citizens of the state they're
not going through Refugee programs and
so forth I don't want to commingle the
two um because I think we're trying to
get to is the refugees or people who are
using the funds that probably shouldn't
have the ability to use it but I'm not
really sure I understand exactly what
you're trying to get to because many of
those dollars are legitimate dollars and
you're trying to get into fraudulent
behavior and I don't know how we can
break it apart do you have any way to
break it apart and let us know so thank
you uh representative I I reject the use
of the word Refugee in this debate I've
I've I've tried to make it as clear as
possible that I'm not talking about the
refugee resettlement program so I'm
going to say it again I am not talking
about the refugee resettlement program
I'm talking about the Myriad of DHHS
programs that New Hampshire citizens are
eligible for to help cover their social
determinance of care uh and and I do I I
do think that uh our citizens would
appreciate knowing that we see this wave
coming and that we're trying to do
something we're trying to figure out
something to preserve their place in
line one of the things that I'm picking
up from the news media in New York City
is that the people of Harlem are just
really
incensed that they've been looking for
programs for decade or more that are
just being rolled out on behalf of the
illegal immigrant community and uh and I
think that sort of social anger is
something we should anticipate and we
should tell our own citizens we want to
prioritize you um and and I think that's
actually better for social stability if
we let those people who know who've been
paying into the system who work to pay
into the system that that that they're
our priority and that that's that's sort
of the the theme of what I'm trying to
go with with this bill representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my last question um
representative Edwards um since um
there's been discussion about Asylum
seekers in particular and I'm not sure
what you said and what other people said
but I've heard them referred to as um
you know both people who are fleeing
persecution in their home countries and
I've heard them refer to essentially as
Liars
um different people not maybe not the
same people so given that and given your
statement that um you know you live at
home with your dogs and you're not
really in this world I'm wondering in in
anticipation of going further because as
you say this is an issue that's not
going away
if you would be willing to meet with um
if I could arrange it to meet with some
Asylum Seekers to kind of understand
some of their personal stories um about
the types of persecution they've fleed
and why they have done it and what it's
been like to actually go through the
process of applying for asylum in this
country which um you know I I've heard
some things that say it's kind of
stacked in their favor um I would tend
to disagree with that but any case my
question is would you be willing to meet
with a group of people who um this
discussion really is
affecting so the short answer is yes I
love everyone I want to meet as many
people here as many different points of
view as possible but I would just want
to let you know that as somebody who
spent a year in Afghanistan and two
years in Korea and been worried about
the uh World stability now for 40 years
that understand what that there's real
political persecution in the world I
don't doubt that some people really need
to flee here because of political
persecution political persecution is
protected under our federal law what's
not protected under our federal law are
economic refugees and and so in any
population of about 5 million random
people who are crashing our border there
going to be subsets of people that fall
into different categories and I would
hope as good honest people that we would
be able to accept that there is a fairly
significant class of or subset of that
population who are gaming the system
because they've been trained to gain the
system the materials to game the system
from Tick Tock to pamphlets is in that
IL Al immigration train that is Flowing
up from the south so I I I I I think I I
I think it could be a deflection to
focus on the the set that I'm I'm not
worried about which are the the refugees
that are here legitimately through the
program those people who are
legitimately fleeing political
persecution th those people have you
know my empathy and my support it's it's
those people who are abusing our system
and our good-naturedness uh and I and I
think I just from that group I want to
find a way to distinguish them and
protect our citizens from them thank you
other questions representative Palazo
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my second question uh so in terms
of abusing system I agree with you that
uh some uh uh people who claim political
Asylum actually here for economic
reasons but uh there were some cases uh
Federal cases with body shops when uh
employer uh sponsored uh immigration was
uh illegally abused and system was gamed
and the same there were some legal cases
uh with marriage based immigration when
they were fake marriages so if you ask
our committee to single
out um uh those claiming political
Asylum is it just based on
volume or is it both volume and some
data that that system is more abused
than immigration based for example on
marriage or on uh uh
employment so you make a a fine point
there there are many reasons why
somebody could um um uh get US
citizenship through valid means and and
some of those methods are abused too and
i' I've mentioned political Asylum
almost exclusively as as the category
that I'm talking about and there's a
reason for that is that in these trains
of people that are coming up from south
of Mexico and through Mexico
there are training materials available
to them the cartels are making sure that
the people who are paying them thousands
of dollars to get across the border are
are adequately trained in order to game
our system so they are being taught to
claim political Asylum and that's that's
the eligibility condition that I think
is most abused now now for those people
who are worried about human trafficking
of which I'm one of them
there there are others who are are
abusing that part of it by uh
effectively uh kidnapping kids and using
them to to to bring families across and
then there are reports about how the
child once it gets through the process
gets sent back so that they could be
used again to support another group of
of uh illegal immigrants so so this
whole situation at the border is just
Madness and I I don't and I think it's
an existential threat to the nation too
by the way but but for now all I want to
do is tell New Hampshire
taxpayers we know you've paid into the
system we know you've built this system
and and you're our priority and we know
that there are the this other category
categories maybe of people who uh are in
other jurisdictions taking from the
taxpayers those benefits that are
rightly the the per province of the
taxpayers they're
essentially well I'm not I want to say
stealing they're not stealing it because
you know elected people are giving it to
them but but but they're but it's being
taken away from taxpayers improperly and
I want to tell our citizens we're not
going to let that happen in New
Hampshire does that answer your question
so other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you I didn't realize this was
going to take this long but I I do
appreciate uh the audience and the
questions and um if there's anything I
can do to further help with this process
Edwards just to review it's been the
practice of this committee uh that the
prime sponsor gets extra time to explain
the background of of the bill and um you
know why it's being introduced and and
uh other input that they may have
received we do ask all testimony to be
kept right around three minutes so that
allows extra time for questions of each
uh each person testifying and also to
make sure that uh everybody has a fair
shot at uh offering testimony to the
committee on the bill uh next person up
to testify and who um asked to testify
is Bob Dunn with the Roman Catholic
bishop of Manchester uh and you've asked
dun yes thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm Bob Dunn the director
of public policy for the Roman Catholic
dasis of Manchester and I'm here today
on behalf of Bishop Peter labashi
respectfully to oppose this bill um my
testimony in opposition to this bill was
to the bill that uh the prime sponsor
has now essentially ask you to itl or to
change in some way so I won't belabor
the issue um the um what I would have
said is that um this is something which
I think uh as representative Edwards
alluded to on its face uh says that uh
people in the refugee program um don't
get services
um if there are unmet services for US
citizens and um we think that just is
not commensurate with human dignity the
folks in the refugee program are here um
under the refugee
program also um the uh Bill strikes me
as something that a more typically would
be found in house bill one or House Bill
two um it is talking about about the
allocation and appropriation and the use
of funds um and so to um pass something
like this takes uh something which uh
infers that it's a closed loop of
services um which it is a closed loop in
the context of the budget because the
budget is deciding what funds can be
appropriated for what purposes but it's
not a closed loop when it's in a advance
of the budget because the budget writers
can make any decision they want about
how funds are going to be allocated uh
so I'll leave it at that and thank you
for your attention and Hospitality okay
thank you any questions representative n
Ram uh thank you for letting me ask a
question thank you for taking my
question just curious um do you have any
idea how much money the Catholic Church
does expend with helping refugees
I I don't I know I know that was and I'm
not sure what categories I I do know
that obviously we we believe that the
Catholic church in New Hampshire is the
largest non-governmental provider of
charitable assistance across the board
how much of that um flows into what
areas I couldn't tell you okay thank you
very
much other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak is Henry Harris
England good morning Mr Harris good
morning you've asked for five to 10
minutes that's I I can I can wrap that
up I clearly it sounds like a lot to
unpack yeah if you could do it in free
that'd be great yeah I can do that so I
mean I think you
know on a I'm not sure this is the
appropriate form to change this bill if
you go back to the 1980 Refugee
resettlement
act
um where that those funds are are
generated for the refugee program which
is federally funded program it's not to
be confused with the Border crisis in
any
way um so I don't I don't even think
that this form is the correct one I'm
not a I'm not a representative I don't
understand the full proceedings but I
believe this would go back to your
you're trying to repurpose funds from an
act from 1980 and I don't think you can
do it from here um which brings me into
my next point do not confuse the refugee
crisis at the that's not or the crisis
at the border is not the refugee program
that settles here in New Hampshire that
is a federally funded program there are
uh compliance standards and check levels
at every process so from the
presidential determination which is
approved by Congress they decide how
many refugees come in it's a fixed
amount of people each year there's
funding and programs provided to support
Refugee
resettlement it is not what's happening
at the border so everyone that comes
here pre- arrival through the refugee
resettlement program goes through years
to get into this this country there's at
each stage there's many vetting
processes out before they even come into
this
country um and they go through
background checks and betting Ved to be
here um refugees enter this country
through that Pro program legally they
are immediately able to work enroll
their kids in school and pay
taxes they are regular citizens they are
allowed to participate in our society as
Citizens so when we talk about These
funds and how they're allocated for New
Hampshire they are in the same category
as every other citizen who is applying
for
benefits um The International Institute
of New England and our colleagues at
centur Care Alliance we've been
resettling refugees in this manner for
over a hundred years this is a
proven process it works well please do
not confuse it with the everything
that's happening at the border that's a
completely different thing from what
this 19 1980 Refugee resettlement Act is
referring to it's completely
different um I believe um we talked
briefly I heard some comments about
we're an aging State um we've got young
people moving away we've got older
people retiring also moving away and or
going on fixed incomes our tax base is
shrinking refugees fit that bill I get
calls weekly from employers around the
state who want to connect with me and
our and our uh clients and get them
employed and we have lots of Pathways
career Pathways where we educate and we
train for what New Hampshire
needs um so I you know I think in
general I think we need to check whether
this is an legal or a legal um way to
approach changing this
bill um if you could start wrapping up
please I will and I think you know
referees taking money away from a proven
program that does work to try to fix
something that's unrelated to what the
original intent of this funding is is
not a responsible
solution because it's taking away from
services that are much needed here to
make people
successful um and I think you know
refugees are um it's an investment and I
think this these funding helps invest in
newcomers to this area who are legal who
are meant to be here thank you any
questions than you
representative n upam thank you um I
missed your name and the name of your
organization oh I'm sorry my name's
Henry Harris I'm the managing director
for The International Institute of New
England and is that um housed in New
Hampshire yeah so we're located in
Manchester okay we have offices in
Boston L and
Manchester okay thank you I run the
Manchester okay thank you other
you hopefully I come close with this
Alliance good morning sir and um again
you've asked for five minutes if you
could keep it closer to three out of
you you turn the microphone
off there you go I'm trying to figure
out five
minutes thank you so much good morning
my name is Jean hakuzimana and I am the
director of asri Care Alliance in the
New Hampshire office we are a cment
agency as well so I have a testimony
that I want to read for you and it's
against HB
1347 chairman W and esteemed members of
Health and Human Services and Affairs
committee good
morning I am here before you today not
only as the New Hampshire state director
of service for new Americans at the
centri alliance but also as
an who has experienced the challenges
and opportunities faced by
newcomers to this country and especially
to this
state I am deeply concerned about the
potential impact HB
1347 on ases and refugees who all aspire
to be part of New Hampshire
Workforce when I arrived in New
Hampshire 5 years ago from Rwanda s
Africa I was eager to work but I
encountered numerous obstacles in my
search for employment despite my 10
years of experience in communication in
Africa and the bachelor's degree in
journalism I struggled to find a job
matching my
qualifications I even had the
opportunity to work for the United
Nations development program instead I
took on physical demanding work in
Industries like construction to make end
me navigating my new home in the United
States was challenging fit but after
leaving my construction job I enrolled
in a community development policy and
practice program graduate courses and I
paid it free from my funds and um I was
also doing two jobs and caring for my
family I'm a father of four kids so my
experience is not unique many refugees
and ases they have the similar
challenges when they try to enter the
workforce in this state language
barriers cultural differences lack of
recognition of their foreign credentials
they prevent often those people like me
to access meaningful
life uh one of many accomplishment that
I had in this state is starting a
company that is called in New Hampshire
sa and I organized the conf called
moving together
conversations last year in November the
conference was
organized to convene industry and
Business Leaders about the value and
importance of immigrants in New
Hampshire Workforce especially so
Business Review voted my conference as
the best conference to bring diverse
voes voices in the state you can start
wrapping up please sir sure I am so uh
additionally I believe people like me
have been part of the solution in this
state especially comes to Workforce
Development and additionally household
like mine we are bringing a lot
of money and injection into the economy
of these states and we believe that is
valuable for all of us to consider when
you have a be like this in front of you
lawmakers thank you so much thank you
any
much no one else has signed up to
1347 oh represent I mean attorney uh
Williams I don't have a pink card for
chairman McDonald and members of the
Health Human Services elderly Affairs
committee for the record my name is John
Williams I'm the legislative director
for the New Hampshire Department of
Health Services and with me
is good morning Ruben Hampton director
of office of Health Equity Department of
Health and Human
Services and I just want to thank
committee we'll we'll certainly try to
keep our commentary down to three
minutes or less uh we just want to
clarify a few things that were discussed
I think the committee actually were
getting the answers and is right we just
want to confirm uh with you what our
department understanding is first the
department provided written testimony to
this committee because when we did
conducted our financial analysis on this
bill it was specifically directed to the
New Hampshire Refugee uh um re uh
resettlement program in New Hampshire uh
I want to just make it very clear that
those are 100% General funds that's
getting to represent Merchant's question
when he started uh speaking about the
budgetary appropriation impact of the
bill that these are 100% federally
funded dollars
therefore as as and and out of very good
respect to representative Edwards the
bills Prime sponsor who readily said
we're not working off of the bill that's
in front of you but that's what we did
come prepared to discuss today and just
wanted to make sure you had a common
understanding of some of the the factors
that are involved so uh first off 100%
federally funded so this language to
preclude State funding uh would not
impact that program because it's 100%
federally funded that's number one
number two is the questions regarding
undocumented individuals receiving
assistance uh undocumented individuals
are not um permitted to receiving either
state or federal assistance so just want
to make that clear that was a question
that was asked that they don't receive
it so we just want to clarify that as to
the fraud issue when an individual comes
into Mr Hampton's program that we
administer they go through a federal
vetting so the issue of federal um
preemption and for the attorney Types on
the committee that what it means is that
it's not a state issue necessarily but
it is a federal issue so before coming
to Ruben's uh uh program excuse Mr
Hampton's program they are vetted at the
federal level and they do go through a
screening through Homeland Security
which conducts at least 10 or more uh
various checks uh is there always
potential for fraud I know from your
chairman uh that he served very
dutifully as a fraud investigator and we
do actually as our own agency uh once we
do have all all individuals that we're
serving we do look to fraud to make sure
that's not happening with all the people
that we're serving not just those who
are refugees so the point I think we're
trying to make is before the indivisual
even comes into our program they've gone
through a federal vending and it's the
federal government that makes
determination whether or not they're
granted the uh authority to becoming uh
and receiving those services that is a
lot of winded worded that I said and I
think chairman I would turned it over to
you for questions uh from the committee
but we just wanted to make those points
very very clear as you move forward with
the decision what to do with the underly
Bill and whether or not you want to
conduct uh further study research on the
more larger issue uh that was raised by
the Bill's print sponsor KY Williams is
the refugee cash assistance program
still in effect the eight-month program
that's still there it is currently 12
months but yes it is still in effect
okay great uh representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I just want to be
clear
that the 100% federally funded under the
refugee Act of 1980 those f funds cannot
be diverted to any um social determinant
efforts in the state is that
correct thank you representative mph
those funds can only be used for the
program itself and cannot be redirected
to any social determinant program they
can only be used for the program and its
clients thank
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and thank
um my understanding is um exactly what
you said that if someone is fully
um benefits um correct in the state um
but is it not true in terms of an
earlier question about only citizens
receiving Federal benefits in the state
of New Hampshire that when we apply for
um Medicaid expansion not this P time
but the time before we specifically
requested a waiver to exclude
non-citizens and that was rejected by
government um I I'll take the first
attempt at this uh because that actually
U falls under under social deter to
health we're talking Medicaid and that's
why I took the microphone very quickly
as refo as a prime sponsor for one of
those initiatives I'm sure others uh
that uh certainly New Hampshire and in
this legislature adopted a policy to
extend the coverage for uh pregnant
women and children as it relates uh but
those individuals I are 100% documented
in terms of receiving those assisten
these are not undocumented individuals
and I'm not speaking correctly I'm going
to ask Mr Hampton or anyone else from
our shop behind me to respond to that
toif there's a sometimes a fiveyear
waiting period if you were to come here
and you might not be a citizen but you
might be a a legal resident of this
country right and you know be able to
receive benefits there's typically
fiveyear waiting period for that however
that is removed for uh pregnant women
and children I believe that maybe what
you referring to follow
up thank you Mr chairman actually I'm
speaking more broadly um and um I'm well
aware of that bill but um I'm speaking
more broadly for example um in my
neighborhood in
we have a young Afghan family who came
they were evacuated from
Afghanistan in August two years ago they
worked for the American Military um they
were brought to this country they were
resettled by um a group in Keen but
through a century Care Alliance um that
family received Medicaid as soon as they
got here um and
um they no longer are on Medicaid
because they work and they earn a living
and they get um employment um based
benefits but is it not true that um it
would be illegal for us to ban
noncitizens in New Hampshire from
getting programs like Medicaid and
represent Shiro I always get very
confused when I hear is it not true
because I'm always trying to figure out
which is which I'm just trying to get to
the point um so let's be very very clear
that the individuals are receiving
Medicaid benefits are one documented two
if it's through the um uh program that
Mr hampon administering for Refugee
resettlement they've already gone
through the process of being uh given a
grant and therefore are documented
receiving uh that assistance if they are
not documented then they would not be
entitled to receiving that I just want
to be 100% clear I even took my head
turned it around to our two other
experts and both gave me a nod and I
think they're doing it right now behind
me as I'm
speaking other question representative
Palazo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so if Government
places an into removal
procedures like what what happens then
is there any communication does the
department have a way to know that
immigrant is no longer legally here and
should be self deported or in uh in some
other deportation
procedures individuals who would be
subject to deportation presumably will
have gone through the process and were
denied uh being granted either Refugee
or other status so they would be we
wouldn't see them part of that at least
um unless there's some very odd
circumstance that we're not aware of we
would not see that that would be done
prior to entering into our our
system other
questions I'm seeing no other questions
gentlemen thank
you oh representative
TZ thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question gentlemen can you
help because it is so confusing can you
help describe the various categories of
like the legal status of a refugee um
versus an asy versus a resident versus
someone who's undocumented because I
think they get conflated and there's
terminology related to the legal status
of refugees that I haven't heard stated
yet I I would agree that in hearing the
testimony here that uh we were even
questioning what we're trying to do in
terms of defining uh those various
different categories what I did he
clearly was undocumented individuals I
heard clearly um individuals seeking to
becoming documented but doing it through
fraud uh I've heard about individuals
who have been granted uh Refugee status
um and heading their way to censorship
so those are at least the three
categories that I think I can discern
from the testimony but that's about the
best that I can do uh rather T if unless
there's other questions that you have
but we can certainly describe the
process if that's what you're actually
asking in terms of what is a typical
process for an in individual who becomes
uh given a grant for Refugee status and
then receiving our services I think
that's what you might be asking and if
you're not I will stay here until I can
get it right and or until your chair
says enough
time are you
followup I have heard the status the
legal status of refugees described as
refugees Upon a rival have the full
rights and all um privileges of a
citizen accept the right to vote and
then they are on a particular path
towards you know getting towards
citizenship but that is their legal
status which is very different from
other immigrants and it's part of the
you know infrastructure of of you know
the refugee act and all that I would
agree okay representative Weber um mine
is more a question of the chair but also
a question of uh the folks who are
testifying which is that I wonder I
think it would be very helpful and this
is a follow-up to representative tez's
Point uh but it would be very helpful
for me as one of those people for whom
the various statuses are murky because I
don't work with them all the time if
either the department or perhaps our
researcher could prepare for us a list
of the different statuses
um and what the implications are in
terms of uh benefits received and from
whom because there are as representative
TZ has pointed out any number of
different statuses and those of us who
are less knowledgeable about them tend
to blur the lines and it would be very
helpful to have some kind of list of
what the statuses are
and what what benefits and what what we
do for each of those categories that
would be very
helpful thank you representative Weber
that is something that we can do and
just as a a brief summary of that the
program serves folks who have sending it
along would be great and represent Weber
just uh we will connect uh um the
researcher Miss Dyer uh we actually have
those experts who could have come
prepared but this is not a day for that
Journey for folks to go through that
process no I I was hoping down the road
and in my email
box any other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
gentlemen thank you very much
representative Shapiro is the blue sheet
right there by you on this bill could
okay yeah yeah could you pass that down
pause
records thank you very
much no one else has signed up to
testify on HB 1347 so I'm going to close
the public hearing on HB
1347 and open the public hearing on hb1
1638 FN and recognize the prime sponsor
Penza I saw her picking up a pink card
earlier so I assume that's on the way
somewhere actually she's holding it okay
go we could pass that up represent
just give it to representative Palazo
the pink card I mean I didn't fill it
out yet so okay no that's fine that's
fine okay that's fine or you can do it
after either
way
whoops thank you Mr chair um for the
record my name is representative uh
Kelly Penza straford District 19 um I
put this bill in uh in regards with um
talking to actually one constituent and
then uh having a meeting with um fellow
stakeholders um and just in the essence
of government uh kind of accountability
and
transparency and but before I talk about
this kind of very simple bill um I I
would like to just give a quick story
about um a conversation that I had with
a DHHS employee in Roch Chester I met
her at uh just a a local little coffee
hole and she can't she actually uh has
only been in New Hampshire for a short
period of time and um and it was just
really refreshing to hear um you know
the the changes that are going on uh
within her um within her department and
um you know you're always going to have
folks in in any agency in any Department
in every governmental branch that are
you know you're going to have some bad
apples and I think this bill um helps
that process I think it helps um I think
it helps people that are in charge um
holding you know uh staff accountable
and because this woman that was from New
York had told me that you know this New
Hampshire is light years away from what
she was experiencing but there could
still be some improvements and so I had
told her about this bill and she says I
think that's a fantastic idea so hearing
it specifically from the horse's mouth
um I just thought that this was uh a
very simple bill that could if people
have a
pattern um a history of issues uh that
there is a process that we don't keep
people in the system so um or employees
in a system that is um already
completely overwhelmed and taxed and
burdened uh in every way form so these
these workers um have a lot of
responsibilities they have um um they
have huge tasks in front of them so I
just thought that this would help help
this process keeping good people
rewarding good people as well as uh you
know keeping people accountable that's
it thank you any questions
representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
um if I'm not mistaken I heard you said
that you would this was this idea came
out of a conversation with a
constituent and I'm wondering um in
further conversations have you found
this issue to be generalizable I mean is
it
like rather than one particular
situation have you found it to be um a
situation that comes up frequently and
I'm not talking about um misconduct or
um you know failure to do the job
properly but um have have you generally
found that there were a lot of problems
with supervising um employees who are
not performing um adequately and
um whatever giving consequences or
giving the opportunity to for job
Improvement um so my question basically
is have you found this to be generally a
problem yeah I can't really speak to
that I think the point of the bill um is
is process and I think that this is
really good process that we should have
in place I'm going to to read you one
line so the review shall Encompass a
detailed examination of all the records
related to their job performance
including their responses to delegated
tasks for the prior 3 years if the
examination were reveals a pattern of
failure to perform their duties as
required the employee
shall the employee shall be placed on
probation and receive remedial training
I think that's the point like this that
is the most important line to me of this
bill and because I there's not a review
process that's seeing if someone is has
a pattern and I just think that this
could it just should be helpful I know
that if I was not
performing my job let's just say as a
legislator and you've got people that
are making um you know constant
complaints and stuff like that and
there's no there's no follow through
there's no that you know it's kind of
like your complaints are kind of falling
on deaf ears I just think that this is
it's good it's good to I would want to
know how I could improve in my job and I
I just think that um everybody should
should want this I think it's good for
the agency I think it's good for all of
us follow up thank you um so
I'm two follow-ups um one is really why
you limited this to Department of Health
and Human Services why not all of state
government and second of all do you um
do you can you tell us what the current
process is within DHHS when an employee
inadequately so
if in the statute it talks about what
the process is in a very general sense
and um I just wanted to make it more
specific so um I had a conversation uh
with that employee that works underneath
the HHS and she told me kind of what
happens now and this doesn't happen and
that's the only reason why that this was
put in this was put in like that um and
I just uh I wanted to focus on DHHS
because I I just um this bill if it was
overall would have been more uh will I
file this again um next year for another
agency I probably
will so let's just hit take down one at
a time representative Weber and then
representative Murphy I believe that the
answer to representative Shapiro's um uh
question has also answered I had a very
similar thrust so thank you thank you
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question I it somewhat piggybacks off of
Representative Shapiro and Weber's
question but my specific question is are
you aware that there's a and I'm not you
know in any organization I've been in
there's an HR department that normally
handles complaints and you know those
type of misconduct issues are you aware
that DHHS or other agencies does not
have a HR department to handle
these so most HR departments so if I
have a complaint I'm not going to an HR
department that that usually is if
you're an employee not if you're an
outside um um entity person that is that
has experienced a problem usually you're
going directly to
um you know a person at the top for
example I was I had contacted uh DHHS uh
concerning a con a constituent about a
um this had to do with a child care
issue I went directly to I I went
directly to a manager that manager
brought me um to an employ uh to the
lawyer for DHHS so they don't bring you
to an HR department that is usually
happens within so it's employee employee
um you know Superior to an employee
that's not usually a pathway for someone
on the outside going
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you for taking the
question in regards to the issue of what
I call customer service is this more
like if someone gets disgruntled because
they don't get what they wish to receive
that's more of a customer service issue
than it really is to to represent
Murphy's issue the employee not doing
the job so so that how do we understand
how do we break this apart with somebody
who doesn't get what they want and they
consider a bad customer service versus
somebody who's really having a
problem I know I think it simply covers
that so it basically says right here in
the beginning the commissioner shall
direct the department to adopt the rules
that require all employees who have been
found by virtue of a complaint filed in
their normal course so how how someone
that has been grieved through you know
the the agency they have to follow a
normal process so that's already in that
in place so it's not it it's not just a
um you know a customer service issue
because it has to then it continues to
have failed their it has to be proven so
they failed to perform their job
properly it goes through the normal
process that they would already be doing
it's just now adding
on okay so is there been a pattern of
follow up thank you Mr chman having
worked with the public for over 20
years and been um subject to a lot of
customer service issues it's very hard
for anyone at least for myself to
distinguish between somebody having
really poor customer service because
they didn't get what they want versus
poor customer service because the
employee didn't provide reasonableness
if you will so I just think this is kind
of a slippy slope in trying to Define
what customer service should be and how
we get to it can you help me understand
and how we're going to break apart poor
performance okay the commissioner is
already doing that so if I Lodge a
complaint let's say for example I Lodge
a complaint against
dcyf that complaint has been
investigated and found valid through the
commissioner and that person has is the
process has happened they've already
said that they failed to perform their
job properly
so that so this isn't a you know this
isn't just a complaint board and then
everybody it it still has to go through
due
process okay other
questions representative
TZ uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I um I'm a little
confused by the example you provided I
think it was helpful to differentiate
that this is not an HR uh issue uh are
you aware of sort of what the current um
requirements for staff performance
review are and and if you're not I I'm
sure we'll hear from someone from the
Department um and then are you how does
this intersect with the ombudsman's
office which exists to uh deal with uh
concerns from uh people who are
receiving services or you know interact
so this isn't um I didn't I didn't
incorporate the omn omnibud in this
process so it's it's basically whatever
the
current the current process that the
agency is providing in regards with um
job
performance it's adding on to look if
there is a pattern if there's a history
that's really um I I know what I they do
provide R medal training I know those
things that are already happening um
it's just adding in to see if there's a
pattern and if there is a pattern that
um you know three years then there
should be something that comes after
that because there could just be an if
you fail to perform and fail to perform
and fail to perform and there's
no yeah that that's really kind of the
the whole point of
this and I and I think that all of us
should be all of us should want um
should want that especially for you know
public employees uh you know everybody
should want that and I think about even
in um law
enforcement all of that stuff I think is
extremely important there has to be a a
process and I think this piece of the
process is
missing other
also signed up to speak our attorney Rob
Barry and Barbara mccan from the
Services good morning Mr chair members
of the committee my name is robberry I'm
the general counsel to the division of
Medicaid at the department of healthy
and services however before that uh
position I was the HR attorney with the
HHS for over 5 years I also served two
years as the employee relations
administrator with the Department of
Health and Human
Services I'm Barbara mccan the interim
human resource director for Health and
Human Services and uh thank
you uh so we'll Begin by um stating we
do not position on the uh on the bill
but we are concerned about it um the
primary issue we're concerned about is
that it creates uh some massive confus
Fusion as to the current process um
currently the department of
administrative Services through the
division of personnel is responsible for
promulgating personnel rules uh across
the entire spectrum of state
employment uh there is a process in
there for discipline it is laid out very
clearly you can look at peer
administrative rule peer 1000
2.04 through 08 and that'll give you the
entire process for letters of warnings
suspensions
terminations uh and things of that
nature um so there is a process to laid
out in law as it stands this bill
essentially gives the Commissioner of
Health un Services the ability
to um usurp I guess for lack of a better
word div the director of the division of
personnel's uh Authority in terms of uh
promulgating rules and it serves to
create some massive confusion in the
process that's already laid out
that one of the um items that was
mentioned was that uh about performance
reviews so we do um under the Personnel
rules for the State of New Hampshire do
um annual performance reviews and in
that um there are goals set if someone
is underperforming and those are looked
at while um we also go through any kind
of discipline process there's a look
back period of five years so additional
um and any kind of pattern that might
show up um would be addressed during
that
period representative Shapiro and then
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question um if I was a little bit more
Nimble I would have looked up those
rules already but uh I'm afraid I'm not
that Nimble and I maybe you can tell me
where I can find them um however I I
think the sponsor of this bill referred
to this piece of the process is missing
and I think she was referring
specifically to the part of like looking
back over 3 years to see if there was a
pattern of I don't know either
misbehavior or um inadequate performance
or I guess a variety of things and is it
true that this piece of the process is
missing or is uh or is a um pattern of
problematic performance taken into
account in um in job reviews um so I
would not agree that this pattern is not
taken into account um as part of my
duties with general counsel to HR uh I I
prosecuted I'd say well over 20 appeals
at the Personnel appeals board uh one of
my main concerns when considering what
sort of discipline was appropriate for
an employee was a pattern of behavior so
pattern is absolutely uh considered when
determining discipline uh and like uh
Miss can allude it to we actually go
back five years as opposed to
three our representative Weber I believe
was next then representative Lon thank
you very much Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Mr
chairman and U not speaker yet I don't
think I
want my apologies and thank you for
taking my question my question is um
is I'm wondering if there isn't a
benefit
to having uh the department of
administrative Services be the people
setting the overview for this rather
than having the
department uh look at it internally
because we have a more um uh if I'm
understanding the process there is a
more independent review and oversight
that would be missing if we
gave the department the full authority
to deal with these
issues yeah I think that's true um part
of the uh the disciplinary review
process when an employee is disciplined
they have appeal rights um they can go
through up to four steps depending on
the appeal terminations will
automatically go to the last step
actually that's a fifth step at the
personel appeals board um but the fourth
step in the informal dispute resolution
process is the division of personnel and
it's heard by the division director uh
who is independent from DHHS and uh will
uh determine whether the discipline
issued by DHHS was
appropriate thank you representative Lon
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here to answer questions um my
question is how can people make sure
that they have a complaint so that they
can register it because there may be a
disconnect between people's ability to
uh to basically bring this to somebody's
attention and the process well so we
have the udman as I believe
representative tez mentioned that they
are individuals who are responsible for
um processing and evaluating uh citizen
complaints if they are concerned about
something they do pass it on to
supervisors for for further review uh
individuals can go through supervisors
they can go through uh the
Commissioner's Office it wasn't uncommon
for me when I was in the HR realm to get
things filtered down uh from as high up
as sometimes the governor's office it
it's not uncommon for it to happen so
there is a process for coming for
complaints being uh processed and
evaluated as represented Merchant was
referring to uh earlier sometimes it may
be that people just don't like the
result of the the
outcome okay that seems a little complex
for people but I guess we have multiple
channels to feed in yeah there is really
no wrong door it does get to where it
needs to be um people are well aware of
um so if it goes anywhere it's going to
get to the person who needs to evaluate
it it does happen it's very rare when
something gets just completely dropped
um I can't even think of an example but
we do have a process in
place representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
I have to say I enjoyed reading this
bill because this is exactly how I rais
my children so um the part that I like
the most about the bill that I would
like you to address is on line um 11 or
10 of the bill where it says not only
you identify there's a problem um and
place them on probation but the part
where they get remedial training and it
says and get remedial training it's
implied in that bill that they are going
to get that and I think too often we
criticize people without trying to help
them what is the process now that you do
with regards to that so whenever
anybody's issued a um uh any discipline
that's less than termination uh they are
issued a performance Improvement plan or
corrective action plan uh where we put
in there what they need to do to avoid
further discipline often times that will
involve remedial training if it's uh
something particularly with case uh
review or things like that so what my
process was when I was the attorney and
the employee relations administrator uh
assisting supervisors with determining
what a corrective action plan would look
like I would always ask what trainings
can you give somebody to to improve this
how do we make this employee successful
because um the
it's a lot of effort to go through a
personal appeals board um uh you know uh
process and we also want people to
succeed so we always give people plenty
of opportunity to succeed and if they
hadn't been given that you know that
rudimentary training or the you know the
talking to about what they're doing
wrong um we would often say you need to
take this extra step before we go down
that step you need to give them a chance
to succeed before you can pursue uh you
know serious discipline
well is that process in the rules that
you referred to earlier miss m wants to
actually add something well I wanted to
say um before an employee gets to the
discipline process those also any kind
of performance issues are identified
during the performance evaluations and
in in the supervisors will also create
um trainings or goals corrective actions
as well um early on so it's more
performance Improvement and before we
get to the discipline process
okay representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and taking our
wondering um what's measured in that
review um when you do the look back of
the fiveyear period um is there you know
are you looking at just procedures are
you receiving like I'm talking about the
administrative um Department a Personnel
I guess are they getting um are they
getting help in evaluating based on the
specific division that the person Works
in and the rules that and laws that
govern that specific department or
division or is it kind of just a broad
um you know your work's done on time
your reports are filed you've met your
continuing
education um and you have no discipline
or is it very specific each department
works the division of personnel has
created uh templates that we use for
performance evaluation each template is
specific towards the job so there might
be a technical there might be a
managerial more of a support template
that people would use and in those
evaluation forms there are up to 25
bullet points of things that we look at
and there's a sliding scale of
below expectation to exceeds expectation
that the supervisors will review
annually with with the person in regards
to their job description and and their
performance followup thank you and is
there anything in those requirements
that measures or um kind of audits uh
you'll see in the bill it says putting
lives at Great risk on on line 11 and I
think maybe that definition needs to be
tightened up um my concern is with
constitutional rights of the people that
are served by the government agencies is
there any audit on whether um a person
is uh effectively upholding the
Constitution and ensuring they're not
infringing on the the rights of the
people and is there any training to that
employees well so endangering the life
of a uh a citizen of the state is
already outlined in the Personnel roles
is a terminable offense um so it's not
something that is um we don't have to go
through the you know the step process
there you if you're found to have uh
engaged in behavior that was potentially
dangerous um you can be terminated
immediately uh as for trainings I'm not
up to speed on what's going on trainings
wise across the entire department other
than your basic um you know um privacy
security um confidentiality
uh you know sexual harassment policies
and things like that so your standard HR
uh trainings but um I haven't been
engaged in that in a couple of years so
there could be new things that I'm not
aware
of other representative
Palazo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I I wonder what
can prevent termination of Po performing
employees and for
example is it true that some of the CH
employes are
unionized and protected by some Union
agreement to L extent from being
terminated so the collective bargaining
agreement for state employees through
the state employees Association does not
Encompass discipline that is completely
within the realm of the Personnel rules
uh the collective bargaining agreement
for state employees is uh centered on
the terms and conditions of employment
representative Murphy representative
Merchant and then representative kersman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the
question as I listened to the
conversation about the employee being
bombarded by a citizen of our state what
protection do the employee have
from unil unrespectful behavior of the
citizen of the state do they have any
rights or any way to protect them from
somebody who become so disgruntled they
don't get what they want and take it out
of the employees is there any way to
protect the employee from that behavior
and very very extreme circumstances and
I can't remember the last time this has
happened we will seek out restraining
orders against individuals it doesn't
happen very often and I can't even
remember the last time it happened um
but there is that process in place if
it's necessary but it's got to be very
very extreme Behavior not simply uh
disgruntled uh citizens or people who
are just trying to be make a nuisance of
themselves representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman um I know that you
alluded to it and you said that there
are multiple channels to to Lodge a
complaint but say I kind of want to walk
through that explore it a little bit
more so say I um in receiving um you
know
I I think if I can say I bring in a
complaint to the
Ombudsman and then you know I've I've
received complaints personally as a
representative that fell on deaf ears
according to the people who brought them
to me so I'm seeing a different story
than what you're saying is happening
that all the complaints eventually end
up you know being
processed and then determined to be
founded or not
founded um can you walk us through that
a little bit like is there a phone
number Central phone number someone can
call to Lodge a complaint can you walk
in and file a
complaint well all of our uh information
is posted online but the EMB budman's
number is online but you can look up my
my information my phone number is online
uh people can give me a call and people
do give me a call to talk about things
that are not related to my job at all
and what I do with that is I send it to
the right person and because I've worked
there for 10 years now I know enough
people to how to get it to them but when
it comes to employee conduct one thing
to remember is the results of those
investigations are not going to be
public they unless an individual is
issue discipline and they appeal it to
the Personnel appeals board that's a
public process everything else is not
going to be public so a lot of times
people will hear we took appropriate
action and sometimes that means we
terminated that employee but we cannot
tell you that because um they have not
appealed it so that can be not
satisfying um answer for people but
that's how it is in the Personnel rules
it's we're supposed to be confidential
it's also in the collective bargaining
agreement um and then sometimes the
complaints are simply just unfounded um
it's a disgruntle citizen for whatever
reason um and they just don't like to
hear that uh that answer so um you know
we do take complaints very very
seriously because we are aware of what
we do in in New Hampshire and what we're
responsible for for doing so so um you
know I can assure you that we do um
process complaints and take appropriate
action as
necessary representative
TZ uh thank you and thank you for taking
my question so as a followup to that is
that data compiled sort of in aggregate
you know deidentified manner you know we
had X number of complaints and you know
X were resolved and maybe they were
resolved in different ways like is that
uh anywhere I don't know about
complaints
Barbara in in our office we have an
employee relations unit and obviously um
we track all the discipline processes
and even if they don't rise to
discipline if it was a complaint that's
investigated but um in regards to your
answer I I don't think there is a a RIS
unless yeah unless the udman keeps a
complaint um but you know HR does
compile the the disciplinary uh
processes for sure and I mean I can
speak from experience on this um when I
was hired at the department as the um
General Council of the Bureau of elderly
and Adult
Services um and my the HR attorney
position was not even in my job
description and I was given the position
um I will say I spent probably 80 to 95%
of my time handling um employee
discipline um there is a lot um that
goes on and we do uh spend a lot of time
trying to ensure that employees are
performing their jobs adequately
followup so as a follow up I guess just
uh steming off representative kushman's
question I think there's this desire for
just having some evidence whether it's
at the department of personnel level or
DHHS level just to be able to show
people yes you are getting you know data
and aggregate you are getting complaints
you are managing them and you are
handling them and you are resolving them
without giving away any details just
it's possible we could compile that but
I can't say for sure that we could um so
we might be able to do disciplinary
numbers for the Department uh to tie it
to a number of complaints um because
complaints are going to be come in all
shapes and size is not necessarily about
employees sometimes they could just be
complaining about a department process
in general that has nothing to do with
employees specifically so that might be
hard to um to show but I we can
definitely show an aggregate in terms of
um of discipline um another thing that's
public is the Personnel appeals board
has a record of all their um the current
appeals going on so you can see there's
quite a few probably I haven't looked in
a while but there there was one point in
my life where I was probably the most
common attorney up at the uh at the
personel felds
board representative Leon and then
representative kosman uh thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking another
question um so my my question is I mean
we we've unfortunately seen um a case
that I think we all hope had been
handled differently and that Harmony was
still here if um there were complaints
that people made that they weren't sure
if it was followed up on do do people
report that they had reported something
that then wasn't followed up on and how
would that be handled because we want to
make sure that that everything we can
pursue whether or not a complaint was
ignored and not processed by an employee
or something else is sort of handled in
this process because I understand you're
trying to have a seeve where everything
is coming from through and those with
with Merit follow through but how do we
ensure that the plates are handled
appropriately by employees so that
we we don't potentially miss um this
happening to somebody else are you
asking how the legislature does that no
I'm asking how how the department of
personnel follows up to make sure that
people are actually appropriately
recording complaints that are coming
through um if somebody's worried about a
child I can't speak to what the division
of personnel does because it's a
different agency it's part of the
administrative Services um all I can
speak to is what um HHS does and um we
stand by the fact that we process
complaints appropriately and we take
appropriate action based on what the
complaint is and what we can verify okay
and so sorry followup follow up um and
so even if you can't verify something
you have a way that you know that you
got a report you got a record you
weren't able to verify it so that's
something that could be followed up if
there is an employee who tends to find
certain cases
non-verified so if an employee is put
under investigation and there is no
action taken what we do is we put
together a a letter that we provide to
the employee saying that you know you
were under investigation no further
action has been taken but that's not
placed in their personnel file because
we're not allowed to place in their
personnel file for the Personnel rules
we can only put discipline in there okay
I think I might try and follow up on you
to get a better understanding of the
process okay representative
kushman I'm also set thank you thank you
representative palazov thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so the bill is written is
talking about five steps and I wonder
how the steps currently lie between D
HHS and division of personnel so I'm
talking about First Step Job review
Second Step casee review third step
probation fourth remedial training and
fifth termination so
currently is is it all directed by
division of personnel or are some of
those steps would be directed by U uh
Administration in DS could you explain
so the agency for which the employee
works is going to handle the
disciplinary
investigation um administra Services
only comes into it if through the appeal
process and to maintain the individual's
personnel file so if their discipline is
issued um the um the document is
provided to administrative services for
place in to place in their file but
everything else is going to be handled
at the agency level not just DHHS but
safety Corrections whoever the agency
is other
could somebody give me the blue sheet uh
Christina perhaps or oh you have another
another
card also signed up to speak is Bob blaz
Dell uh from the New Hampshire state
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um as stated earlier um for
the record my name is Bob blazel
representing the state employees
Association of New
Hampshire uh I took a look at this bill
and I wasn't I was I wasn't quite sure
um what the what the goal was here um so
I wanted to come in and and and listen
to the to the sponsor and I wasn't quite
sure I was going to speak but based on
what I've I've heard so far U I think
I'm going to make just a few comments if
I
may
um on line four it refers to by by
virtue of of
complaint uh I guess uh one of the
concerns might be here is what what
constitutes a
complaint um is it external is it
internal um we it's it's not uh
necessarily made made clear there um I
did want to bring to the committee's
attention that on line 10 where it talks
about placing an employee on on
probation um this this would be in
direct um conflict with RSA 273 A1 U
where it states that the probationary
period um cannot exceed a year I don't
believe there's a mechanism to put um an
existing employee that's already
completed their probationary Year back
on
probation uh so that's um as I think one
of the previous speakers me mentioned
this uh this I think the words were
massive confusion um I would I would
tend to agree with with
that um line 10 it's we're talking
excuse me line 12 we're we're um talking
terminated the Personnel
rules provide for a currently they
provide for a totality of circumstances
test to determine the appropriate level
of
discipline um in in any given situation
um as is stated in the bill um shall be
terminated that that language
essentially removes any balancing test
um any ability to to consider the length
of employment past performance um or um
any other disciplinary options that are
on the
table um I will refer you
to person rules uh 102 period
03 um Section
3 um excuse me 03 um section c excuse me
um there was I believe the the sponsor
was talking about um we need to get back
at um past
performance um I'm just going to read
this to you it's very very quick um the
employees past record of performance and
discipline including whether or not the
employee has been disciplined in the
past um for the same or similar offense
that's that's already in in the current
Personnel rules so I'm I'm I am I guess
at a loss um I'm I'm looking at at these
rules and I'm I'm happy Mr chairman to
leave um these Personnel rules with you
um if it's if it's helpful for the
committee um and I could be mistaken um
but I I I think I may have heard the
sponsor mention that that she had um
conferred with some stakeholders um as
every legislative comes across my desk
um for the state employees I'm their
senior lobbyist um I've I've never been
consulted um regarding this I'm happy to
have more
conversations um you email those
personnels to all the members of the
committee oh oh oh okay all right thank
you okay never mind um so that's that's
um just want to make sure I covered
everything uh yeah that's just that's my
thoughts for the day um if I can try and
answer any questions right now I
certainly will do so thank you
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you providing all of
this information um my the one thing
that really caught my attention was that
you said that there could be mitigating
factors to not terminate an employee
with a pattern of putting lives at Great
risk could you help me understand how
there could be mitigating factors if
someone has a history of putting lives
I'm sorry did you say that I said
something yes you called out
online um you called out on line 11 in
the event that an employee has a pattern
of putting lives at Great risk the
employee shall be terminated um I'm not
sure if you hadn't closely read before
that that comma saying that it's only
for those employees who have placed
lives at Great risk um because I
understand that you already have
policies around termination um but I'm
trying and you spoke to mitigating
factors I'm just trying to understand if
there could be a mitigating factor to
having a pattern of putting lives at
Great
risk I am I'm not going to try and
pretend to to speak for the agency
whether it be um Health and Human
Services or any other agency um I would
very much like to believe that if there
was an existing pattern um already about
putting lives at risk that that matter
would be addressed in a quick and quick
manner thank you
representative Merchant you had a
question on which RSA were yeah could
you uh repeat the RSA that was in the
that RSA
273- a colon
1 and that would be in Roman numeral 9
section D where it says no employee
shall be determined to be in a
probationary status who shall have been
employed for more than 12 months thank
you yes
questions yeah I'm saying none I
appreciate your time would you like this
for the file or oh sure okay may I
approach
much hey are there any other pink cards
floating out there that I haven't seen
yet uh I don't think so no one else has
signed up to speak and one person had
signed up on the blue sheet posos to the
U to the bill and I will pull that up
and we'll find out who may have signed
against online there's three in support
and one
opposed and with that I going to close
the public hearing on HB
1638 those are the only bills we had
noticed for P for public hearings today
uh so we are going to adjourn the public
hearings and we'll be going into
executive
session uh to the members of the
committee does anybody need a break
before we proceed representative n upam
wants a break uh how about a 10-minute
session
e
ready okay I think most of us are here
and I know a couple will be in
momentarily um first bill to be
considered in executive session today
will be HB 1171 and I'll represent
recognize representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman I would move that we
adopt amendment
2024-25
to House Bill
second representative kofalt seconds
representative um this has been passed
around this is an amendment um that
removes um an old pilot program from one
of the charges of the commission and it
also um makes it so that the the report
detailing the data sharing between
between de and DHHS only have have to
happen annually instead of at a minimum
that was what a request from the
Department um I drafted this amendment
in conjunction with uh the prime sponsor
Nancy Murphy um I am a member of the
commission I think it does good work I
think that this little bit of
housekeeping while we're here is a good
effort and I hope that we can have the
support for both the amendment and the
bill okay any other
discussion seeing none okay
I have a second yes co-al a
second did I did I hear somebody wanted
to say something else okay but the
motion is out to pass on Amendment 2024
hyen 0213 H I'll ask the cl to call the
rooll representative Lon yes
representative
krishman representative King Bill King
yes representative uh cofal
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth
King representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative pza yes representative
Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative
fedus um
representative hacken Phillips
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representative
TZ yes and represented McDonald yes 17
to zer three not in
attendance
okay um I had kushman yeah Seth
King so it was uh kushman Seth King and
fedus um okay
predus okay now do I have a motion uh
another motion um yes I move a to pass
as amended on House Bill 1171 second uh
representative Merchant seconds you wish
to speak a motion um I I think it's
largely being covered okay when the
clerk is ready any well any
discussion seeing none clerk is
writing motion is ought to pass as
amended on HB
1171 representative Lan yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative copal yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth
King representative Missour yes yes
representative Nagel yes representative
palosa
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative hackin Phillips
yes representative n upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
bommer yes representative tez
yes and representative McDonald
yes amend
190 to
one okay if there's no objection we'll
put that on the consent
calendar okay moving on the next bill to
be considered in executive session today
is hb1 1231 do I have a motion
representative L on um thank you Mr
chairman I would like to move Amendment
uh 2024-25
and I'll pass that out okay is there a
second representative Shiro seconds
could I have that number again please
02026 so
02026 I'm thinking this is the right
number to come this
way that's too many digits sorry there
there are two different amendments to
this bill they're both complimentary
they catch different things it is 0
zero so
0206 is the one we're discussing correct
but the one we have is the other one
it's coming through this way we'll do
the two of them so this um so to speak
to this amendment um the first section
um I prepared this with representative
Thomas uh the first one catches the word
on on it says with instead of within 21
days the other one is the same one that
representative Shapiro caught that it
should be 2024 not
2023 um I believe he can speak to his
Amendment after we do that but the two
of them are
complimentary I'm sorry I I don't have
the paper yet and I have completely
gotten garbled as to what we're voting
on right now can can you wait till we
get the amendment in front of us and
then explain it that would be really
helpful yeah thank you well we'll give
them I'm a visual learner I'm perfectly
happy
to read while you're explaining I just
need it in front of
me who was second on the bill uh
representative Shapero I believe
you just my own clarification we are on
the amendment
0206 yes and once I see that the
amendment is in everybody's hands I'll
tell you exactly where where it is I
appreciate yes they were pretty simple
so I figured it would be all right to
mention it
twice um those ones can go around as
well um well we'll do it just one second
um so if you look on line 10 um that in
the original bill says with not within
so that it reads reported to the
department within the prior 21 days
instead of reported to the department
with the 20 prior 21 days and then the
other change um in 17 on Lane 17 is
changing it to 2024 instead of
2023 just simple clerical changes thank
any
discussion I'm seeing none so the motion
is ought to pass on Amendment 2024 hyen
ready representative Leon yes yes
representative Leah kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth
King representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative
pza
yes representative Weber yes
representative fedus yes representative
hackin Phillips
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative tez
yes and representative McDonald yes
one representative Shapero do you have a
motion on the next Amendment yes Mr
chairman I move that we adopt Amendment
d816h to House Bill 1231 thank you is
there second I'll second representative
Le on seconds representative chaparo do
you wish to speak to your motion yes um
when Dr Dr Jerry kerk testified he um
informed us that the medical oversight
board was in favor of this homegrown
legislation but he did point out one
problem and that is on page five lines
about it basically talks about who would
be precluded from prosecution for
possession and it includes people who
are not were kind of far along in their
approval of having a qualified condition
but not fully um fully qualified and so
um we just thought that that was too
confusing people who were in that
situation could wait um and um it
created an enforcement um confusion that
shouldn't be in there so um Amendment
0816 um just does away with um section
D it also it also on the top it also
catches the same date um change that was
already we already passed in the
previous
Amendment thank you any other
discussion seeing none motion is ought
to pass on Amendment 2024
d816h on House Bill
1231 on the CL is ready representative
Lon yes representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative copal yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative poov
yes representative Weber yes
yes representative fedus yes
representative hackin Phillips yes
represent nut upam yes representative
Shapiro yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes representive tez yes and
representative McDonald yes 19 0 to
one there's no objection we'll put it no
that's just the amendment I always do
that don't
I okay representative Shapiro do you
have another
motion UT pass is amended order pass is
amended I move order pass is amended on
House Bill 1231 not second and
representative Le on seconds any further
discussion representative uh Merchant
more for clarification when we say as
amended since there's two amendments we
have to be sure we have both
there representative Weber what will
happen is that OS will take the two
amendments given that they are in
completely different sections and they
will create a committee amendment that
will have a different amendment number
but it will be created of both of these
and we should of course check that when
the calendar comes out but that's that's
what happens when we have two of these
thank you representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman um I'm I'm going to oppose
this for the exact same reasons that I
opposed it last year um I also am on the
therapeutic commission or cannabis
oversight commission and I was the one
person who voted against this there as
well um this is all about cost and
access which I totally get the system of
alternative treatment centers that we've
created is inefficient it doesn't work
it can be a lot better than it is but I
do think it's the best mechanism to
solve the problem um having toured
multiple um cultivation centers I
realize the complexity that goes into
making a reliable product and if you're
going to have a medicinal product it
needs to be reliable we found out from
not only testimony but I'm talking to
the folks there that for an individual
to grow this at home the likelihood that
they're going to be able to create a
reliable product is extremely expensive
and extremely unlikely so very few
people are going to do this anyways
what I would really like to see us do is
instead of going down this road is try
to reform the ATC um um um process and
get more centers out closer to people
than we have right now um also to get
rid of the nonprofit status to stop
making them responsible for the entire
cost of the program because that's what
makes the prices so high and start to
look at programs around us and the
states around us to see how they do it
so that we can mimic them to make it
more cost effective than it is um but
that's why I'm going to vote against
it any other discussion representative
Missour yes thank you um for the same
reasons I'll be opposing it as well I am
not against um therapeutic cannabis use
but I did hear we did hear from law
enforcement and their oversight of this
they said would be very difficult and
challenging and I'm want to listen to
that and I have some constituents who
are not super comfortable with this so
for those reasons just for this one um
I'm going to I'm going to oppose it sure
representative um
Merchant I hear about the law
enforcement I think law enforcement had
a real challenge specifically with page
five lines 13 through 18 since those
have been deleted I think the issue
about enforcement becomes less
problematic and therefore I'll support
the bill representative Nal did you have
your hand up I I did and I I think one
of there's two other issues that I
wanted to raise number one is I want to
emphasize that we're talking about
cannabis as an ingested smoked plant um
um there are actually THC and CBD
formulations that are FD approve FDA
approved and they are scheduled three so
it's not like people don't have access
to this already the other concern that's
been raised at the State Health
assessment meetings as well as at this
meeting as well as and this is my pun
for the day is that we do have a budding
problem with with um with cannabis use
disorder I mean it it's a big
unrecognized problem and and um if you
look back to the early 1900s why we've
created cannabis and opioid legislation
in the first place was it was a national
security issue that we were seeing a
problems with addictions to both and we
didn't have a stable force of young
people to work to support to secure our
country and things like that that was
the impetus for create those bills in
the first place and what's very
concerning is we're seeing between fenil
cannabis other things like that the same
thing again I just see these things as
slippery slopes that are taking us down
of questionable Road other
discussion say no other discussion
motion motion is out to pass is amended
on HB
1231 representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King no
representative kofalt
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth
King representative Missour
no representative uh Nagel
no representative Palo
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative hackin Phillips yes
representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representative TZ
yes representative McDonald
no surprised
me uh 15 to
four 10 One n one
okay so that that I assume canot go on
consent
um
okay sentive Shapiro you're writing the
you I'm sorry will there be a minority
minority report sorry
um yeah what day why don't you write
that and would that be an itl for the
minority
again I need I need any reports
today not my rule the speaker's rule
so okay uh representative Shapiro had to
leave
and don't know if it's really feasible
1240 is that representative Fon is that
something we were considering or um I
I'm not sure or if uh we're going to be
able to do one more bill in six minutes
or if we're going to uh try and do that
after we're back that's that
10:42 yes 1042 um actually at 10:42
should be quick if we want to okay do
1042 all right then let let's proceed to
10:42
then uh do I have a motion on
1042 representative Merchant I have a
sure I'd like to speak to Amendment 2024
d07
17h I will second and that's moving
I'll meet
you easy is good easy is not your
typical fourl word no thank you Mr
chairman uh so you made a motion did I
have a he a second I'll second
representative Le on second I'm sorry
represen kofalt I'm sorry um would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Merchant yes I would
chairman although the intent of this
bill initially back in 2017 was well
intended after listening to a lot of
testimony took from the Board of
Pharmacy and their lack of documentation
this has actually done anything to
reduce an error or show a reduction in
error and so forth
Etc and recognizing that this is a best
practice really not something should be
Quantified in statute um we looked at
other professions uh they don't have
something comparable to this it's my
recommendation to this committee that is
signed to repeal the Bill appeal the RSA
to uh let us get back to best practice
and not put best practice into the
statute any other
discussion Mr chair oh yes
representative Missour I just have a
quick question so I was subbing in a
committee the other day and they it was
brought up that if there was an
amendment that everyone there was no big
controversy and that everyone was going
to be voting on they could go straight
to otpa no no because they and never
heard that well did
more uh I I do believe it can be a show
of hands when it's not controversial uh
but it does need to be voted
on well let's let's unless it's a strong
objection I think we should do the rooll
call represent much appreciate I think
be uh any other discussion or any other
questions heing on motion is ought to
pass on uh Amendment 2024 hyen
0717 to House Bill
1042 representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
representative Missour yes
representative n
yes representative pza
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative heckin Phillips
yes representative nut upam
yes representative
Shapiro representative
Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representative tez
yes representative McDonald
yes 180 and
two I do I have another motion motion
ought to pass is amended thank you is
there a second second representative
kofalt seconds any
discussion seeing none I'll ask when
he's ready uh motion is ought to pass as
1042 representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King
representative Missour yes repr Nagel
yes representative Palo yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
representative hecken Phillips yes
representative nut upam yes
representative
Shapiro representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes represent Palmer yes representative
tez yes yes and represented McDonald
yes 180 and
two consent yeah there's no
objection go on
consent okay it is now noon and we we
agreed that we we'd break at noon until
1:10 so we'll be in recess for the next
I'll got
go
e
good afternoon and welcome back uh we'll
continue our executive session from from
this morning um and the next bill up is
a HB
1318 uh do I have a motion on that I
have an amendment that I handed out okay
okay representative Nel oh and I'd like
to make a motion um that we uh ought to
2024-25
on House Bill
1318 do I have a second second
representative Merchant seconds
representative Nagel do you want to
speak to your motion I will be as
succinct as possible um so just as a a
background um most of you heard the
original discussion on this but there's
been a problem in balancing the needs of
people in pain and people with addiction
with regard to opioids for over 120
years and we've never managed to hit The
Sweet Spot since the Pol public policies
of 2016 we've really gone the wrong
direction in terms of tilting things in
favor of people with a addiction and
harming people with pain um the opioid
abatement um trust funds that were
created unfortunately exacerbate that
dramatically by causing a substantial
redistribution of wealth from one group
to another without um acknowledging the
needs of people in pain so the whole
purpose of this bill was to actually try
to bring the system back into balance
what was exciting about the discussion
that we had with attorney um petti was
that it brought us together to sit down
chat about this in a lot greater detail
his concern was that anything that we do
has to be opioid sparing so these
amendments are are modified to try to
preserve his concerns um anyways with
that said I'm going to go there's two uh
specific numbers number 19 and number 18
both have been one more amended than the
other one um and number 19 the only
change I made and that was acknowledging
some people's concerns on the opio
abatement commission that they didn't
understand what public and non-public
Services meant and I didn't either um so
I just removed those words that's the
only change in 19 um the reason why we
have number 19 is that everybody is
saying well you don't need to prescribe
opioids you can give them all these
other services that we provide them no
access to the point of 19 was to create
novel programs such as what we created
in
h66 that we can put together
costeffective integrative care to be
opioid sparing and and give people
access to other types of care when
they're in pain um number 18 the only
change that I made in number 18 was to
be very specific about what kind of
programs could be used um as I stated on
uh original testimony we have a huge
problem with what are called opioid
refugees people that were doing very
well in opioid therapy but are being
denied access to care and being subject
to
non-consensual dose reductions
detoxifications or outright abandoned
and they have nowhere to go this is like
a national humongous problem that we're
trying to solve and we have no homes for
them so what I did or what I added to
this um and I ran up by attorney
buffetti was that we created a support
Med medication assisted uh treatment
type Services which I'd be happy to
explain in Greater depth if anybody
wishes U so we'd be very specific about
what kind of programs that we could
develop um to give these people a home
to go to a safe haven if you will after
they've been abandoned because right now
they don't have anywhere to
go representative
Weber I was just going to state that my
concern with this bill was the um
interface with the settlement agreement
and uh with the involvement of Mr buetti
and the um amendments that have been
made I'm much more comfortable so I
would thank you for that I I did want to
say also that what I tried really hard
to do with both of these amendments is
to make them number one
evidence-based which they are mat
programs have like Decades of evidence
to support them uh integrative care
plans have Decades of exper of uh
evidencebased and the other thing is
these are both consistent with Schedule
E of the settlement funds and and we've
discussed this also in the opioid
abatement commission and there's
widespread agreement these are
important other discussion
representative
Merchant I want to say thank you to
representative Nel for uh the amendment
I think it does in my opinion two things
which I talked about before my analogy
with the bathtub it deals with
medication assisted treatment programs
to help people who need to be treated
who have an addiction it helps in that
Arena which is what I call draining the
bathtub but at the same time it does
talk about trying to find under section
19 line 14 ways to treat patients with
nonopiate treatment Alternatives so I
think in a lot of ways this tackles
concern I had we're not just trying to
empty the bathtub but we're trying to
avoid filling it at the same time
therefore I'll support it thank you
other
discussion saying none okay the motion
is ought to pass on Amendment 2024
hyphen
0424 to Amendment uh oh to House Bill
1318 Mr Clark representative L yes
representative kushman yes
representative bill K yes representative
Copo yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative pelosa
yes representative Weber yes
fedus representative hacken Phillips
yes representative nut upam
yes representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
tez
yes and representative McDonald yes 19
to
zero okay Mr representative Nal would
you like to make another motion I'd like
to make a motion on um pass House Bill
0424 representative Merchant seconds any
other
discussion representative
palaza my my initial concern with this
bill if was if the app abatement is a
proper place uh for this measures but uh
I'm happy with the explanation that we
need br bring back uh system into
balance and we need to respect the need
of patients who give informed consent
for pain
management uh and uh I think this bill
helps us bring back to risk benefit
analysis and best practices so I will
support it okay thank you other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the cler
to follow all motion is ought to pass as
amended on HB 13
18 representative Leon yes yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel
yes representative poosa yes
representative Weber
yes repres representative McKay yes
representative
fedus representative hackin Phillips
yes representative Nutter Upham
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative Tes yes and
represent McDonald yes 19 to zero
consent okay there's no objection we'll
put that on
consent okay next up is uh HB 1067
representative Seth King I believe you
motion I have an amendment should I hand
so while that's being handed out I'd
like to make a motion of ought to pass
a
second representative Le on
seconds do you wish to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair um
so this amendment removes the first two
paragraphs of the original Bill and
keeps the third paragraph in its
entirety I don't think there was enough
support for the original bill as is um
really at all I think the I I know
personally I would not have been able to
support the original bill um I don't
like the idea of compelling doctors
against their conscience to either
perform an operation or to even be
forced to do the leg work and find um
find out somebody who would perform the
operation for the patient I think the
patient can do that on their own um this
this amendment does keep I think a
really good part of the bill which is
basically saying that if somebody does
choose to get sterilized they don't get
to later have regrets and then sue the
doctor because oops I can't have
children um I believe in treating adults
like adults and you have to be willing
to take the consequences of your actions
when you make these decisions so this
still requires a patient to sign a
waiver and all that stuff they know what
they're getting into um the sponsor of
the bill I think one of her main
contentions was that a lot of doctors
aren't willing to perform sterilization
specifically uh for women because out of
some sort of like paternalistic ideas I
don't really see it that way um I I tend
to think that most doctors are just
afraid of getting sued after the fact
unfortunately uh we don't have any
doctors that testified to explain why
they were unwilling to do these
procedures so we can only speculate
that's my speculation is they're just
afraid of getting sued and and this
really helps protect them this way
adults can be adult they can make
decisions uh concerning their bodies and
uh and if they later have regrets that's
very unfortunate but they they signed
the waiver you know so this way doctors
can do it without fear so other
discussion representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and I want to thank
representative King for bringing this
amendment um I I think that the idea of
a doctor not performing an otherwise
medically necessary procedure because
they're concerned about the person's
future repr
reproductive plans is a problem I really
would like to have a way that we could
have figured out how to get Section A to
work but when I was I I don't think that
that's something that we were going to
be able to come to any sort of language
on how to do that and I think that um
the effort the representative King has
in this to basically make it clear that
somebody can't sue for that reason um
hopefully we'll alleviate all those
concerns from doctors that are otherwise
not providing care that is warranted um
so you know I'd like to see a little bit
more on um somebody who's being denied
uh treatment for severe endometriosis
because of concerns about the
reproductive capacity but I think that
this is something that I think we'll
actually be able to do something
constructive for the people of New
Hampshire by passing this so I think
that um while well maybe I'd like to
take more I think that this is a really
good path forward and I hope everybody
can support this other discussion
representative
Weber thank you very much well I'm very
much in favor of the amendment and I
thank repres representative King for
bringing it because I think it solves a
number of really thorny issues and I too
want to say that um you know we had very
compelling testimony about people who
underwent experiences where where people
were incredibly judgmental and
Incredibly condescending about people's
um decisions and and also about their me
the actual medical care um I'm still in
two minds of about whether I'm going to
vote for the underlying bill or not
because I have a conceptual problem
placing individual medical procedures in
the patients Bill of
Rights um that doesn't seem to me to be
the right place for it but um so I
haven't decided how I'm voting on the
underlying bill but I I do see this is a
as a definite step in the right
direction and I appreciate the approach
representative Murphy and then
representative Shapero thank you Mr
chairman um one one of my questions is
to representative King as to why um we
would not just eliminate um in the
paragraph treatment against medical
advice so whether it's against medical
advice or not and somebody has a
sterilization procedure they should
probably not be held liable if down the
road they realize they they're infered
so my question is do we really need that
against medical advice in there um and
then as to the original Bill and its
intent I I can't assign intent to
whatever any provider has uh determined
was the right course of action for the
treatment of a patient so I won't even
try to go there or infer any intent but
when you ask a surgeon to do a procedure
that they don't feel as indicated or for
whatever reason that's the wrong surgeon
for you you do not want that surgeon
operating on you so so let me give you a
concrete example example outside of
obstetric in another specially that
begins with o Orthopedics if you have a
patient that has a BMI of say 50 or 60
so they are entire they're very large
they have diabetes whatever it is any
comorbidity or just a BMI that's very
hard and they have an underlying
diagnosis of arthritis in the knee it's
oftentimes not the proper course of
action to do a total replacement on that
patient there is huge increased risk
associated with that so language to me
is that patients may have an indication
to have a procedure but the physician or
the provider's judgment is such that
they don't think is the most appropriate
course of action for you and I'm not
trying and I won't you know you can say
I don't like big heavy people but I you
know in your heart that they're doomed
to have a failure so I I just can't
assume or assign intent for any
providers that we have heard from um in
prior testimony so um again I'm not
convinced as how I'll go with the um
original Bill uh but I do want to ask
you about should we even have treatment
against medical advice and just be all
inclusive about anybody that has a
sterilization procedure be absolved of
any potential uh risk or liability if
they were properly in uh informed of
their risk
involved would to answer sure uh thank
you for the question um so your second
part had to do with um
forgotten was the second part the first
part was about the St the should that
part be in there and then the second
um oh
yes I I definitely I definitely agree
with you there the um um doctors
shouldn't be forced to do anything and
and this doesn't this with the remaining
like the remaining bill doesn't require
them to do anything so if if they do
think the BMI is too high in a
hysterctomy for for example would be too
dangerous they have every right to opt
out and this bill would not force them
to do anything um the the sterilization
treatment against medical device to me
that just sounds like if there is a
doctor that is willing to perform a
hysterectomy on somebody who does have
in their opinion too high of a BMI um
that it just protects them against
lawsuit later as long as the patient has
been well informed of all the risks of
of doing so
so representative Shapiro and then
um I agree with much of what has been
said um in terms of how compelling the
sponsor story was and wishing we could
do something about that I didn't feel
quite the same as about some of the
other people who were talking about
feeling like they were discriminated or
made to be self-conscious about getting
vasectomies but the the major sponsor I
felt was very compelling and I can't
really figure out what we should do
about that but it doesn't seem like we
have a
solution in terms of the um Amendment
itself that you're
bringing I totally agree with the
sentiment um but to use your terminology
why are we adding more code rather than
less code and why why is this really
necessary because this what what you're
describing is true of any medical
procedure that somebody can sue but
someone has to prove
that there was some kind of misconduct
or you know in I don't know what the
terminology misconduct or wrongdoing um
so why should we why should we put this
one in statute as opposed to just um
figuring that the same process that
applies to hand surgery or knee surgery
or any other medical procedure would
apply representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman I know a little bit about hips
and knees probably not on the putting
them inside as much as Dr Murphy but I
do about the approval the um
reimbursement and the entire
manufacturing process of them um in that
situation implanting a knee and somebody
with a BMI of 50 there's clinical data
showing that there actually are adverse
outcomes by doing that um I I think that
if we were to change this to remove that
against medical advice and give this
protection I recognize that it's adding
a specific area of cod but we have done
that in other areas too if you if if
women are being denied life-saving
health care because doctors are worried
about being sued that would be a reason
to put something into the patient's Bill
of Rights and when you look at the
endometriosis you look at some of the
other things that could lead to that you
would might need a hysterectomy to treat
and when that's being denied because of
what seems to be a fear of being sued
because of um because the person won't
be able to conceive in the future I
think that's one of the areas where it
is important for the government to step
in and say that there is specific
protection here uh this is just one of
those areas that is so tough I I know
women who never wanted children and then
had children and they love them I know
other women that never wanted children
and they're not going to say it out loud
but they kind of wish it hadn't happened
anyways um and some of them perpetuated
cycles of abuse I mean it can be a
challenge but when you're looking at a
woman who has a medical condition and is
denied treatment for what seems to be
just concerned about future f
as opposed to dealing with a true and
present medical condition I I think that
it is the role of the state to do
something here and I believe that adding
that protection from a lawsuit um based
upon the future childbearing capacity in
a sterilization um even if it's not
against medical advice is a good step
forward in order to ensure that women
people are getting this life-saving
what is to prevent
a provider having a patient sign a
consent
form against the risk and so forth Etc
what I'm thinking about is you can sign
yourself out of a
hospital against medical
advice so what I'm trying to understand
is why we need this spill to begin with
why can't there be a form that the
position has or provider has that
clearly
articulates what the downside is and so
forth you're absolving me of all of the
responsibilities and so forth I've told
you everything I need to tell you and
you still want to go forward I'll be
glad to honor that request is because
you fully understand it I'm not an
attorney I'm looking at least two of me
um why can't that form be signed by the
patient
today representative
Nel I think I'm answering what you're
saying because it was a question that I
kind of raised and I I
um I don't know how bu find ing these
things are you know I just because I
have somebody sign something they still
can come back and sue me later and I'm
just I don't know what the legalities of
this are I'm almost starting to wonder
if we're straying into the wrong
commission for this committee for this
bill and you know like somebody would
have more expertise on on the question
you just asked because I don't know and
I've been told a million times when we
when I designed my own inform consense
representative
Weber thank you and I'm I'm not an
expert on inform consent uh but I'm
remembering my first school
superintendent who said nothing I can
tell you will prevent you from being
sued a lot of what I can tell you can
keep you from being sued
successfully um so there is that
distinction um but I think that what
both of you are working towards is
exactly what I was saying originally
this is the wrong place in the statute
if we were to do it it doesn't belong in
the patients Bill of Rights it belongs
in the statute that deals with civil
actions
against um Physicians if there's one
that's very specific but and and there's
I'm sure there are because I can
remember the medical panels and all of
that stuff so it it belongs in a
completely different section of the
statute and it belongs in the Judiciary
Committee when we're talking about
limitations of liability because they
are the committee that deals with that
and um in that respect I do wonder if
this is something that we might not want
to interim study um in terms of um
getting a more
comprehensive approach and getting it to
the right committee next time around
representative Merchant then me
representative Shapiro then
representative
Merchant yes thank you Mr chairman I I
wonder um if I could ask the lawyer in
the room who may not be an expert in
this area but is a lawyer uh what does
it mean shall have no Civil Right of
action does that mean they can't sue or
does that mean they can't win a
sue it it the words say to me and I'll
defer to representative kofalt if
because I'm an elder law attorney and I
haven't been since
1996 in another state but it it means
that there is no cause of action but I
don't know whether this
con uh conflict specifically with items
in the civil litigation parts of our
statutes which may say something very
different and and you know I just don't
know the answer to
that representative merchant do you
question if this is not an early bill
can we reassign this to another
committee once we've got a hearing on it
we can you can't push it over no the
second
committee representative
King thank you Mr chair so I'm not
opposed to interim study um I'm a I'm a
firm believer that um Speedy legislation
is a bad idea and I think we should take
take things slowly and and do it right I
don't like the idea of just even if I
like the intent and I like the idea I'd
rather it get done right in the right
Committee in the right way so I know I
I'm I'm in favor of it but I also like
the idea of it being passed in a
bipartisan Manner and if it's going to
be divisive I'd rather it not be I'd
rather it go to interim study so that's
just my two sents representative
Lon thank you um I was going to say that
I thought that this was going to get
more support from this approach I
actually would like to be able to take a
look at pairing down item a and I'm
curious if we would be okay to um
withdraw the motion U and then move this
one to March 20th if we don't have that
would be our last day to exec if we come
here and we don't have a solution then I
think it would become an easy interim
study but I'd like to have a little bit
more more time to deal with the fact
that important medical procedures are
being put off because of somebody's
reproductive would beate um I think that
March 20th will be our cleanup date and
I we could do March 6 but there's a few
other bills to to focus on by then I'd
like to be able to have the time to look
at this and quite frankly I'm looking at
doing some ma some U major work ahead of
March 6 on other bills so I wouldn't be
able to give it the time that I want um
before March 20th our representative
Merchant is
if that's to be done which I think makes
a lot of sense is this permissible to
Move It from this RSA to another RSA
where it belongs can we do that or we
have to go through another
hearing no representative Weber I
believe and I'd be glad to be corrected
by Miss Dyer if she has thoughts on it
but I I don't think that moving it from
one spot in the statute to another spot
in the statute is going to have an
effect
um I mean we certainly do move things
around
um the other question I was going to ask
Miss Dyer is um there's no reason why we
can't simply leave things the way they
are and and if we recess this hearing we
start with the amendment on the floor we
start with the amendment right we don't
have to withdraw the amendment before to
to recess the hearing we just start
where we left off off is that correct uh
so I have no objection to giving it more
time representative Lon um thank you um
I do know that some other bills and some
other committees because of change
statutes have been ruled on gerain if I
do find that there's a different section
of of the statutes it's appropriate then
I'll work with the chairman to see about
a non gerain um Amendment hearing should
that be necessary ahead of that March
yes yes so any uh hearing on that would
have to happen well ahead of that
representative palazov then
representative thank you Mr chair I will
join the majority if you want to recess
it but my preference is to pass at least
something to help those suffering
because I see it as an issue that
probably still exist but it might not
exist in a couple years because culture
is changing in the past it was no to
have many kids now now it's not so much
so I think Physicians will are catching
up with the current uh uh time so I see
this issue could solve itself like maybe
next year maybe in two years so but if
it still exist maybe if we pass at least
this um minus
in representative Nel um I have two
comments one
um when we were hearing the hearing it's
a lot of times is as representative King
said sometimes the voice that's not in
the room is the most important voice
when somebody comes in and brings a bill
forward who've seen six different
doctors from very different perspectives
all of them said they don't think the
surgery is a good idea that raises some
red flags that maybe not doing the
surgery was the right idea um I we don't
know because they weren't here and they
didn't Testify the other thing I wanted
to raise was I suppose the futility of
this kind of
thing so I've been sued once in my
entire medical career and um I got this
notice that I was being sued there were
five other doctors involved all five of
us were being sued the reason we were
being sued as failure to diagnose and
treat I diagnosed the person and I
initiated therapy for this specific
diagnosis the minute I saw her so I
thought well all right fine they'll let
me off so um and the other four missed
the diagnosis which I don't blame them
it it was in my field it wasn't in there
so anyways so I thought well that's
great we're done I'm going home the next
thing I find out is that nope we're
going to continue we're just going to
even find another creative reason to sue
you and $20,000 of legal expenses later
and you know yeah sure I didn't I got
found without a problem or innocent or
whatever term you want to use but
$20,000 stress and time I'm not sure
these things actually ever prevent
anything and that is the point of what
we're trying to accomplish with this
amendment is to prevent
it other
discussion all right so what's the
pleasure of the committee we G to
representative
Weber so just recess the whole thing
until March
20th is that does that is that agreeable
to
everyone all right so we will recess
20th okay next up is
1194 uh do I have a
motion representative mlan I'd like to
move an amendment Mr chair which I'm
going to hand out
okay that that's coming around guess
got
it they made they made
22 just not enough
another
more well they made me
22 you didn't give her way to anybody
over
okay I'll second his motion
representative on second the motion of V
amendment
okay okay does everybody have a copy of
the amendment representative mlan would
you like to speak to your motion yes uh
I thank you Mr chair I mean I'll be
brief um there was uh some concern
brought up um uh in in testimony about
this bill that um when you go about
redefining uh what is a non-communicable
disease that it may leave um exposed
tetus and there was concerns that you
know we wanted to maintain uh
vaccination for tetanus so um I in in in
the interest of of providing something
that's palatable for the folks on the
committee um I I put that in as a
compromise and so that um it it it makes
clear that uh vaccination uh for tetus
um thank you Mr chairman um the idea of
whether or not we include tetanus in
this is kind of a non-issue under age
seven because you can't receive any of
the other childhood vac you can't
receive the rest of the full pallet of
childhood vaccinations without having
the tetanus shot in the combined ones
that you get below h s but tetanus is a
very nasty disease that is irreversible
um as it goes along you can stop it in
its process but we don't really want to
see people going through that that
terrible situation
um I think that it should be very clear
that in public health if we are if we
are requiring any vaccines it should be
so that stops human to human
transmission because that's the whole
argument is the herd immunity so when
you're talking about something that
doesn't have person-to person
transmission I think the argument in the
case is a lot weaker so by narrowing up
our statutes I think that that will help
to um I just think that'll help to have
greater public support as we are
recognizing threats in the future um so
while I don't think that the addition of
accept accept this is actually necessary
to protect our kids I'm very happy to
include it in order to address the
concerns that we had received in uh in
people's responses and
Merchant I'm struggling with the two
words infectious and
transmittable not sure they are separate
from each other and mutually exclusive
therefore isn't one the same I'm not a
English major but I think I'm looking at
the two saying if something's infectious
is probably transmittable but
something's probably transmittable could
be infectious so I'm not quite sure
exactly what we're trying to do here
representative mlan thank you Mr J um
it's my understanding that infectious is
is not necessarily transmissible from
person to person I could have for
example a flesh eating disease which is
very rare but you know can kind of go
through and consume my body uh so it is
infectious but it's not transmissible so
that was my understanding if the if the
legal understanding however is that
infectious and transmissible uh from
person to person are synonymous then I
think that would just reinforce uh the
fact that it it doesn't really need to
be there so if if legally they they're
synonymous I don't think that you would
need it there um but but if but I I I
think from the testimony the
understanding was no infectious is
something that can go through your body
and spread through your body but it's
not necessarily transmissible person to
person representative kushman and then
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman um yeah I was just going to
give my my feedback um I was taught in
nursing school infectious disease is any
disease it could be caused by a fomite
which is an object that may have some
something on it um that's not person to
person um or it could be like malaria
where there's a vector um a mosquito in
that case not person to person those are
you could even just have pneumonia um
that is a secondary infection from
bronchitis or something that's not
communicable it's not transmitted from
person to person but it is
infectious representative Weber and then
representative
Nel thank you um my concern is the uh
transmissible with removing infectious
is if only have transmissible from
person to person then we have removed
all of the vector diseases and as we
know we have a lot of them and they
we're getting more and um I don't want
to stand in the way of a treatment if
there is one um I I just think this is
unnecessary and inadvisable so I'm going
to vote uh I I I might vote Yes on the
amendment because it makes a little more
clear but um I'm really a no on
everything representative Nagal and then
representative
Shapiro microphone I have a comment and
a question um I mean the comment is
infectious to me means viral bacterial
or fungal I I think that's pretty
straightforward but the question is um
in this chapter child
means um 18 and under and I and I do
know that you do receive tetanus
vaccinations like you know after seven
if you have exposure I mean you're
supposed to get them up for you every 10
years or so so that that would I mean if
if we assume that that's the definition
of child which it says in statute then
then that that does become important as
its own separate thing I think that's my
impression representative
Shapero yes um I'm wondering if
it's possible always possible to discern
what's
transmittable personto person and what
not and I I would defer to
representative kushman who knows more
about this than me or one of the other
medical providers for the um malaria has
been um brought up I had a bad case of
malaria at one point and my
understanding is
that that mosquito that gave me malaria
bit somebody else who had malaria and so
it's not being directly transmitted but
it's still being transmitted from person
to person so I'm just wondering if you
can really be so clear in all cases
about what's transmitted person to
person and what
isn't representative kushman um well if
you like if you look at the at any
disease like go to the CDC website it'll
tell you how is this transmitted fomite
vector or is it communicable is a human
to human transmission so I mean they are
distinguished are is considered a vector
born it can yes it came through someone
else who was infected but there's a
there's another variable in that Chain
of
Infection and some diseases also can be
transmitted to that Vector from an
animal as well and we can't control wild
animals in their vaccination uptake um
so the way I look at it is yes it it can
be delineated and it is in in
practice representative
pmer thank you Mr chair and I I
appreciate the the amendment because
tetus was one of the big things that I
was concerned about initially but I
think that I'm also concerned about
unintended consequences and malaria is a
great example and while we don't have a
lot of it here now and I'm just going to
use this as an example with climate
change we may and the problem that we
get into is that while it is a mosquito
that you need you also need a reservoir
and the reservoir is humans and now that
there's a vaccine for malaria it'll be
really interesting to see what happens
in the countries that have significant
amounts of malaria as more and more
people get immunized and that Reservoir
goes away so there's now when the
mosquito bites somebody they're less
likely to have malaria so then when you
get bitten by that mosquito you're not
going to be so I guess my my objection
to the over bill is that is that there
are a lot of things that may happen in
the future that we don't know and you
know 20 years from now I I don't want us
to have to enact new legislation to get
rid of this so that we can give the
malaria vaccine to our kids because now
it's a real
problem other discussion representative
kushman thank you um so respectfully
there are alternatives to preventing
malaria people already take um
antivirals you know monthly or every six
months in Africa to prevent malaria and
you know we we can't legislate on what
potentially will happen in the
future so I think right now we have this
in front of us with the understanding
that the whole premise of the the state
even being able to mandate any vaccine
on any person is due to the common good
that might be at stake right and so if a
if a disease is non-com communicable
there's no common good to be working for
and we're leaving tetanus in here you
know as a as a olive branch um and to
alleviate concerns about this one
disease that I personally don't believe
that the state has any right to tell
parents to that they have to give their
children anyway because it can't be
transmitted to other children um so I
think for what we have right in front of
us right now now this is the right thing
to do we're just correcting this
definition this was an oversight that
this term infectious was left here um
because the statute was trying to say
that you know the whole intent of this
part of the statute was to say no
noncommunicable diseases shall be have
vaccinations required of our our
citizens so we're we're just correcting
this and if there is a drastic need and
we find that we have a an epidemic of of
um malaria in the United States that the
impetus will be there for the
legislature to come together and do
something about that thank you Miss
Rogers um you mentioned that this uh to
miss da about this being school age but
bill it's in the statute that way okay
I can't hear you yeah could you come up
please thank you Abby Rogers legislative
pleas on division Public Health um I
just want I was telling um Christina
Dyer just as a reminder that this bill
is RSA RSA 141 C20 d a which is the
statute the governs requirements for
school and daycare attendance for
vaccination so just just wanted to
remind you that that's the statute that
that would be affected by this change in
the amendment okay thank you thank you
any any questions for M Rogers while
she's up here or represent
representative
Merchant this goes back to a previous
bill I think probably from last time but
help me understand under the
RSA 141
c2a that allows the department to add
additional vaccines under
541a has the department actually added
any vaccines to the ones listed here in
Statute in rule
making uh do you want to come up um I'm
gonna ask my colleague um am McCurry to
come up to talk she's from the
you good after afternoon I'm am Mar mcir
immunization section chief um it has
been a number of years since any new
immunization requirement has been added
um I think it's been a decade um it's
it's been quite a long time um and the
department does not have any um
additional uh vaccines that we would
like to propose to be added at this time
we're very comfortable with the listing
um I think that we've been very um
conservative in our approach um when we
look at other states there are many
other states that have many more U
vaccine requirements than New Hampshire
does um and I just would like to put out
that um when we're talking about
infectious diseases or non-communicable
diseases um a communicable disease is
one that's infectious or spread by
direct or indirect contact and also
transmissible human to human there are
germs there are pathogens that are
spread um through indirect contact um so
there are viruses that can live on
inanimate surfaces that can be picked up
in later
um you know cause infection um so there
is concern about removing the word
infectious from this disease um and
definition follow
up so basically I understand the process
to go through rul making which is RSA
541a that does require legislative
approval because it has to go through
Jare
absolutely
representative okay our representative n
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I just wanted to make sure
children applies up to age 18 this
definition correct statute uh the
statute reply is um relative to the
school immunization requirements so it
would be any child within the school
systems
okay other discussion representative
palazov thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do we have any data
on health outcome in those less conserv
States regarding vaccination so if they
have more vaccines required uh does it
have higher child mortality or lower
child
mortality could you provide us may lat
with some information on
that thank you for the question um we
could we could see what we could find
for you um and and send it to you
I'm saying
none so the amendment on the the motion
on the floor is out to pass on amendment
20248 09h to House Bill
1194 I'll ask the par to call all
representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Copo
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative pelov
yes representative Weber
yes representative
McKay representative
fedus and representative hecken Phillips
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representative tez
yes and represent McDonald yes 19 to
zero
okay um representative mlan you have a
another motion yes thank you Mr chair um
I would move ought to pass as amended
with Amendment
0809 H motion is there a second
representative mour seconds any
discussion further representative McLean
yeah yeah thank you Mr chair so um I've
been I've been listening uh to the
debate on the amendment and I've been
writing frantically um and so I'm not a
lawyer and I'm not a doctor um but it is
my understanding um that you know the
standards for mandating for
immunizations is that there has to be a
compelling State interest um and so I
kind of take that into account when I'm
looking at this bill John Jay who was
the the first justice of of of the
Supreme Court you know once said that um
in in America the American people are uh
sovereigns without subjects and that's a
large part of where the Dignity of the
American people come from and you know
parents um act as Regents for their
children up until they're able to come
into their own sovereignty and you know
Jay himself recognized the fact that
there's no there's there are limitations
on that sovereignty otherwise you
couldn't have a function in society and
that's implicit in in the social
contract and you know where that
threshold is is to have a compelling
State interest and so you know when I
was looking at some of the case law and
again I'm not a laer but you know in
amongst all the co Wars um you couldn't
help but hear on the radio the The
Jacobson case being referenced over and
over and over again which was uh
Jacobson versus Massachusetts in
1905 Jacobson was a Swedish immigrant
who' been vaccinated back in Sweden uh
he came to the United States and they
had a massive smallpox outbreak in
Cambridge Massachusetts and because of
his bad experience he almost died he
said I don't want to get vacc v inated
um and so the Supreme Court took up that
case and they ruled in fact that yes
indeed the state of Massachusetts could
compel Jacobson to be vaccinated and the
reason was that the threshold of a
compelling State interest was met
because you know one in three people in
Cambridge died and and the the
vaccination
requirement was very limited in a scope
it was just you know in that Metro
Boston area it wasn't even a flying out
in Western Massachusetts you know
certainly not in the entire State and so
I think you know when I look at this
bill I think this bill really is taking
that question of the compelling State
interest head on and it's answering that
question and I think it really
references Jacobson in it's saying that
hey if we have something that is a
transmissible disease such as measles we
know that measles can go into a school
and it can run through the class
classroom like wildfire not everybody is
able to be immunized and so in order to
provide herd immunity in that case then
it's absolutely fine and the threshold
for compelling State interest is met in
requiring immunization for mths measles
or anything like that um and so I think
this bill really clarifies that you know
but my understanding though is that some
of these nonhuman vectors I mean while
they're real and we talked a little bit
about America I don't know uh not
America but um uh malaria
um that it it doesn't rise to that same
level and we could essentially under
that rubric go and start mandating
vaccines for everything and I really
think that we need to be careful and
always air on the side of that
individual sovereignty and and take into
account what that threshold should be I
really think that this bill clarifies
that and uh I'm G to support the bill
representative cofal thank you Mr
chairman um so I think what we've seen
over the past well over the past several
decades since Congress granted blanket
immunity to manufacturers of
vaccines um we have seen as a an
unintended consequences of of that I
think that we have seen a proliferation
of vaccines um including some that are
not mandated in New Hampshire but are
mandated elsewhere uh in cases where
children probably are not at risk um
so you know so so I think we've seen a
proliferation of vaccines we are also
now with mRNA technology seeing a kind
of redefinition of what what a vaccine
is um at one time a vaccine
um meant s of injecting a a a weakened
or dead virus into someone so that they
could develop a natural immunity now
apparently it means something very very
different if I do a Google search for
non uh vaccines for non-communicable
diseases um interestingly it doesn't
bring up tetus but it does bring up a
lot of things that seem to be on the
drawing board um for things like obes
obesity asthma arthritis psoriasis
multiple sclerosis Crohn's disease and
others um the question ultimately will
come down to somebody making the
argument that why would you want to put
your child at risk they should have to
have this
vaccine because indeed that is the
argument that is made about tetus and
others in the case of tetanus it's it's
um I think it's it's a reasonable
argument but it's one of those things
that really needs to be we one at a
time on the other side you see a great
many people not just lay people but you
see a lot of people in the medical
community who have serious reservations
about vaccines and particularly serious
reservations about some of the new
technology that's coming out what this
bill does is essentially say we want to
draw a line in the sand and say there
there
is arguing ably a basis for telling
people
that they need to as as a member of the
herd so to speak they need to um
contribute to the or or participate in
the process I'm not making that argument
I'm simply saying that is the argument
um when it comes to non-communicable
diseases however I think that
argument falls apart and it really comes
down at that point to somebody saying
you ought to do this for your child
because I believe it's good
and that leaves little room for someone
else to say I don't want to do that for
my child because I think it's bad for
them um that ultimately comes down to
the individual rights of of parents to
make the decision that they think are in
the best interest of their children so
while I appreciate that New Hampshire is
actually among the states that has the
shortest list if not the shortest list
one of the shortest lists in the country
of mandated vaccines I think it's
prudent to draw a line and say there is
a point particularly with this shifting
Dynamic of redefining what a vaccine is
and expanding the coverage of vaccines
to to any number of non-communicable
diseases I think it is reasonable and
prudent to uh to set a limit and I think
that this bill does that other
discussion
seeing none okay the motion is out to
pass as amended on HB 1194 ask the
collect to call the role representative
Lon yes representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Copo yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative pelosof yes
representative Weber no representative
McKay
no representative
predus
representative
hackam hacking like a computer hack yeah
I know okay I'm sorry and my vote is no
representative
hackam hackam
Phillips
no representative Nutter
upam representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
no
representative
no Representative taes
no and representative McDonald
yes 11
to8 7 eight in favor I assume there'll
be a Minority Report yes there will be
okay we'll work it out among ourselves
okay yeah again if I could get that
today representative
whoever representative da I mean Miss
Miss da would appreciate it so would M
Miss um
Davis Mr chairman I I just note that
there is no calendar waiting for this
because we are not having session next
week so I understand that you're
desperate to get it done but sure we're
not on Deadline this week sure yeah
again as soon as
um okay next up is HB 1213 FN do I have
a
motion representative kushman thank you
Mr chairman um I move ought to pass on
Amendment uh 202
24-8 1H and that'll be coming around
right
now okay motion was seconded by
representative Missour sorry what was
that number again
representative
08108 okay I had another one from you on
something
else I made that request for
representative mlan I must have typed
looks like everybody has a copy if I may
if you want to proceed sure thank you Mr
chairman and thank you members of the
committee um so this bill as amended um
it would repeal the vaccine
recordkeeping requirement just for the
licensed dayc carees so that the private
schools are no longer part of the bill
uh if you recall uh the recordkeeping
requirement added a burdensome um costly
and timec consuming uh effort on the
part of employees of daycares uh and
schools but uh we're focused on daycares
uh in chasing down and trying to obtain
those records uh we have multiple ways
that parents can maintain their records
in the state of New Hampshire uh their
providers have the records and if they
desire to opt in which most do their
records are in the New Hampshire
immunization information
system and um
this just takes away that burdensome
requirement for the daycares um they
were charged with acting as an
enforcement arm for something that's
required of all children in New
Hampshire whether they attend daycare or
school or not and uh that was an
inappropriate burden to place on them
they are not a part of um the branch of
government that enforces our laws and so
this would just help a struggling
industry um have an easier time to
conduct their
business okay representative South K
thank you Mr chair I'm just a question
for the amendment it seems like we're
watering down the bill a little bit with
the amendment um by getting rid of the
public school part um that was
originally going to be in there and um
so basically we're making it easier for
the child care agencies public or
private but what about private schools
did we want to not allow them to also
kind of opt out of this thanks um So
based on the discussion that was had
during the hearing um and feedback that
we got um the public school I mean the
private school piece of it um was
something that some people were really
stuck on and in the interest of um
getting something across that can help
the daycares at least that's why we
compromise representative Weber
thank you um this does deal with my
concerns about the public schools but uh
so I will probably vote for the
amendment but um if I were the child of
if I were the parent of a child going to
daycare I would want to know what kind
of an environment I was sending my child
to and I think that these kinds of
Records would be something I would want
in making my determination about what
was best for my child and
therefore I think it's ill
advised representative Leon
representative March thank you Mr
chairman and representative Weber um I
recognize your concern there is nothing
in here that would prohibit a Child Care
Agency from collecting these records and
advertising that they that what their
vaccination rates are and letting PE
parents know who are looking for that
what they're looking for um right now we
have a huge burden in child care it
requires more recordkeeping by doing
this some parents are concerned by this
others aren't so by removing this this
mandated burden while allowing childcare
agencies that wish to continue to
collect immunization records it seems
that this is a good way to address that
shortfall and still leave that choice
for parents who are seeking out the
highly immunized
Merchant I think one of the things I
look at
is sharing information we talk about
this in the medical community about
informed consent there's nothing in here
that provides to the parent like an
informed consent whether the Child Care
Agency is going to collect the data or
not so therefore if parent is going to
bring the child to a daycare center not
knowing what the status is of collecting
the data and what they're doing with
immunization I think we're not really
informing the parent adequately to
what's going on so if there was an
informed consent in here the parent is
been
clearly explain to them whether they in
the data what they're doing and they
sign off on it that's a different story
they're just blindly going into it
because they don't have the
information representative
pmer I'm trying to remember um and maybe
somebody can help me is did child care
agencies did they testify in this and
because representative Shapero and then
representative kosman
I would just say that there was some
testimony that it was a problem but
there was also testimony from the the
YMCA of New Hampshire that they were
against this bill and they um
representing all the dayc carees at
their agencies that they are in favor of
this being
you um so I just wanted to speak to the
common misconception that there can be
any guarantee that the child care center
that you're sending your child to
doesn't have any unvaccinated children
because all children in New Hampshire H
have the right to a medical or religious
exemption and it's illegal to
discriminate against somebody being
enrolled in a daycare based on their
religious beliefs or if they have a
disability which both of those
exemptions would fall under um so there
are plenty of unvaccinated kids in
daycare in schools right now that no one
you have no right to know their medical
status um no one does they might have a
religious belief or a medical condition
um that precludes them from
vaccination and um I don't think that
this bill is going to affect that except
that it may allow some day carees to
advertise on the fact that they do
require that record keeping and they
could run on a platform and appeal to
people who are looking for that where
right now um it kind of conflicts with
the
law representative Missour and then
representative Shapiro yes thank you uh
since the YMCA was brought up um yes
they they oppose it but we heard from
several others that they support this
and the thing is with the YMCA even this
bill does not require anyone not to do
that so it's they if the YMCA still
wants to advertise this they can it it
gives them the option to and maybe they
have the Staffing to do all of that that
the other child care agencies that
testified to us didn't so um you know
the the why was one example and as we
know they're a very large organization
that may have adequate Staffing to do
this but many others don't and they are
suffering because of it so we need to
listen to those too representative
Shapero
yes thank you Mr chairman I think we
probably just have conflicting
philosophies about these kinds of things
but I'm going to vote against the Bill
Amend it or not because I feel like the
requirement of reporting vaccinations in
schools is historically part of the
public health fabric that we've
developed in this country and it's one
and of course not every kid who um goes
to a daycare or public school is
um is vaccinated and um in fact we've
had some outbreaks of diseases in Keen
at the local waldor school because a lot
of the parents there don't believe in
vaccinations so it's not a guarantee but
in my mind the reporting to schools
about vaccinations is one of the things
that encourages more kids more families
to be vaccinated which is uh in my mind
is uh a important important Public
Health
um it's important to Public Health and
it I I realize it doesn't do it for
other people for but for me it trumps
people's individual right to not get
vaccinated okay any other
discussion motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 2024 hyen
0810 and ask the clerk to call the rooll
representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Copo
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
Palo yes representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative Nutter upam
Shapiro it's on the amendment yes
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
no representative Palmer
yes representative tez
yes 172 and one
19 17 two to
one okay representative kushman do you
have another motion thank you Mr
chairman yes I move a to pass on House
4810 okay representative coal seconds
any discussion you you wish to speak to
that motion or I think that we we had
enough discussion on the amendment okay
any other discussion seeing none and the
clerk is ready motion is a to pass as
amended on hb1 12113
FN representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Co
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative pza yes
representative Weber no representative
McKay no representative
fedus representative heckin Phillips
no representative Nutter upam no
representative Shapiro
no representative Merchant no
representative Murphy
no representative Palmer no
representative TZ No and representative
voting okay I assume there'll be another
monor
okay okay next up is uh hb1 1240 do I
have a motion i' would like to make a
motion representative Nagel I'd like to
make a motion on HB 1240 and expedient
to
legislate okay is there a second
representative Shapero seconds
representative Nagel do you want to
speak to your motion sure I the first
comments are going to be gerain to the
next three bills but um I'm on the
therapeutic cannabis oversight board and
I just wanted to explain a little bit
about the process the the C the
oversight board did not um support this
bill um generally speaking what's done
is they solicit um evidence-based
reviews um uh on each of the conditions
that comes up um there were two separate
evidence-based uh um uh reviews that
came up one was by somebody I would
consider fairly conservative on this
issue and the other person fairly
liberal and they both agreed to the
evidence
um uh did not support it we will also
accept anecdotal evidence and the
conclusion was there was not sufficient
anecdotal evidence to support uh
therapeutic cannabis for um Eating
Disorders it's important to understand
or know that um the anorexia from an
eating disorder is very different from
the anorexia from say malignancy or
infectious disease or something along
those lines in the eaing disorder the
person is purposely trying to suppress
their appetite
by various means in order to achieve a
distorted body image um the concern was
and there is some evidence for this is
that when you start giving cannabis to
somebody outside the realm of the
complex interdisiplinary treatment they
receive that they engage in binge eating
start and and basically disrupt the
entire treatment process and in the end
it actually turns out to be harmful not
helpful um on the flip side if you have
malignancy with anorexia you don't have
any appetite because of the disease
process so actually uh cannaboids can
actually help that by stimulating your
appetite to achieve a lean body mass the
other issue that was raised that's
really important also is that anorexia
or eating disorders in general complex
disorders there's multiple comorbidities
including um anxiety disorder which
we're going to talk about next um
depression post-traumatic stress
disorder those things are all dealt with
separately and we believe that um each
of these comorbidities should be done
separately and it's perhaps a woman or
whatever with an eaing disorder may
qualify or may be helped based on one of
their other comorbidities but not this
one other representative
Weber well I want to thank
representative Nagel for that because um
it this one was one that I was very much
on the fence about and what had occurred
to me was the issue of um um binging
eating being an eating disorder and it
didn't seem to me like this this was
going to actually help
um and so I really appreciate that
explanation and you have changed me from
a maybe ought to pass to an itl so thank
you representative Shapiro and then
representative
mlan thank you Mr chairman I would just
like to
um add kind of a a larger question which
is since we passed one bill giving
doctors a great deal of discretion not
doctors but providers a great deal of
discretion about um qualifying
People based on their expert opinion is
it time to stop qualifying different
categories for um specific diagnosis
representative nich I I thought the
exact same thing and I mean I think
we're kind of locked in for this year
that we have to do that um I I will say
like um you know my big concern about
all these things is that now I'm
blanking out what I was goingon to say
I'll shut
up representative mlan and then
representative Seth King no I was just
gonna kind of build on representative
Shapiro was kind of going along the same
lines I think there's still value in
having the the the two-tier system for
the reasons that were brought about in
some of the testimony earlier but
certainly this does allow latitude as
new information comes in with the
two-tier system for them to be able to
take advantage of that without having
something that is explicit I think so I
think we're okay I figured out what I
was gonna say okay let representative SE
K go and then I'll go back to
you remember it make keep that thought
hold that thought I'm writing it
down thank you Mr chair um
I I lean on the side of if somebody has
a hangnail they should be able to get
cannabis quite frankly I don't think the
government really has any role in
deciding what reasons you need cannabis
for um that being said I also agree that
uh with representative Shapiro I'm not
really a fan of the idea of having all
these subcategories you know you either
you either get it or you don't we don't
need the government to list every single
disorder um but the world we live in is
we do have that and so we have to decide
whether or not we want to allow uh
something like this to go and so my
question for example Dr Dr Nagel is I'm
not quite sure what the concern is here
are you concerned that somebody who
doesn't really have a dis uh an eating
disorder is going to use that as an
excuse to get cannabis or are you
concerned that somebody who really does
have a an eating disorder is going to
use cannabis and they're going to have
negative
consequences as a result um to me I'm
curious what what the what the answer is
but even even then there there's always
the possibility that somebody who does
have an eating disorder could benefit
from this and for that reason alone I
don't ever want to see somebody have to
go to the doctor's office and lie to the
doctor in order to get the permission
slip to get the medication they believe
they need so thank you
yeah I I mean oh sorry F I'm next okay
you kind of touched on what I wanted to
say anyway so the process right now is
such that you come to me and I have to
have a relationship of some sort with
you so it's not like I'm just meeting
you for the first time so we've had time
to sit down and discuss this there's
also an obligation on my part that I
need to sit down and discuss with you
all these separate diagnoses that we're
coming up with each and every year I
have to decide whether you fulfill one
of those diagnoses or not then I certify
you it goes to the state and then they
basically decide if you qualify or not
at no point am I ever actually
prescribing or doing anything for you
I'm just certifying you have a condition
um is there an ability to lie probably
um one of the concerns that I've had
about the process though is there
assumes when there's a medical
indication or medical use that there's
some level of oversight so if example I
prescribe a blood pressure medicine for
you there's an assumption I'm going to
over oversee that and follow you for
that what I'm finding out now is that
this is what's going on that nobody's
really overseeing this at all we're just
certifying you you're going to a
dispensary you're getting it and you're
just doing what you want the concern
with anorexia was that if somebody
chooses to do that they could since
there is really no oversight well I
shouldn't say there's none in a lot of
cases there's none that they could
actually be harmed by that because now
they're actually creating what they
don't want they're going to create a
binged a large person distorted body
image and they're going to actually set
their care back a a long ways and the
concern with there being no oversight is
that you're going to create a bigger
problem than you start it out with and
and and that's why we believe that this
should not be included as an indication
with that said if the person has a
post-traumatic stress disorder or an
anxiety disorder or anyone of the other
number of indications that they may be
all right but it's really important to
watch and keep keep an eye on them
because they could go off the edge and
actually aggravate the problem not help
it so I hope does that answer your
discussion representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman I'm concerned that we're
getting these various
disorders without any recommendation for
the
professional um uh committee uh dealing
with uh investigating the treatment uh
possibilities so I I feel like I should
not vote for this uh based on the fact
recommendation if they did I'd like to
know what it
two Health Care Providers actually did
an evidence-based review of this
particular um issue and both came to
identical conclusions that there was no
empiric evidence to support this to
support cannabis for this particular
issue now that you've brought that up I
I brought up at the last meeting that I
really think we need expert testimony
before our committee about issues like
this and and as you said it may be moot
now we may not need to do this but
I would love to have like a child an
eating disorder expert come and testify
on to us we don't do that um when they
do these reviews they do have the option
of actually interviewing somebody along
those lines but they do not testify to
US Representative Merchant just to be
short on my records we are doing an is
not an
itl expedient to legisl versus is okay I
thought
I any other representative Weber I was
just clarifying that we are if if you
are opposed to having the
condition included in the statute you're
going to be voting yes on an inexpedient
motion just because we've gotten a
little wound up here so we could just be
clear about this we could vote against
the itl and vote for not yes we could I
won't other
discussion say no other discussion I'll
ask the clerk to call all the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on hp1
1240 representative Leon yes
Representative kushman
no representative Bill King
no representative mlan yes
representative Seth King
no representative Missour
no representative
Nagel uh
yes represent Palo
no representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative
fedus representative representative
hacken phips
yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes representative TZ
yes and representative M McDonald
yes
14-5 and one not
voting will there be a Minority Report
on
that I'm not seeing any yeses I'm not
head
siding I guess well no because I guess
if I have more time than today because I
can't write it now but I can write a
Minority Report on that okay well when
can you get it to me first thing in the
and what will your motion be well it'll
just be against itl no it has be a
motion
okay okay moving on next up is 1349 FN
do I have a
motion representative Nagel um I have a
motion ought to pass on House Bill 13
49 is there a second representative
Missour seconds would you like to speak
to your motion um this will be a lot
reer you already know the process um we
did have one evidence-based review on
this one that came out very supportive
there's abundant anecdotal information
to support the use of cannabis for
anxiety disorder uh in my work with the
NFL um we interview players that are on
um cannabis and uh the vast majority of
them actually take it for anxiety or
sleep disorder not pain interestingly um
But anxiety is the most common reason I
believe that people actually use Canabis
for medicinal reason so it was actually
the unanimous vote of the um um
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board to I'm sorry I'm wrong it was
this okay so your motion is OTP any
other discussion on this motion
representative Murphy this is a question
for um question for representative Nagel
um this a more of a question than a
comment or
otherwise you know obviously we voted or
we we're split on the last one based on
you know um Eating Disorders but now
we've P we're on the track to maybe pass
one for anxiety disorders but my
question is and again from your
perspective where are we going to end up
with you know well we're going to have
to have Bill after Bill after Bill is
when to ask
for all the multiple entities that we're
going to face going down the road and
shouldn't it be a what I'm wondering is
should this bill just be ited as well so
that another build comes in in more of a
general way to term to identify those
disorders uh or should we just assign
that to um the Cannabis commission or
whatever that might be I'm just
wondering how long we're going to keep
you know doing this with multiple bills
and disorders that is an amazingly great
question because I've been involved in
this discussion since that commission
was OB actually created and I would have
never done it the way it's being done
but unfortunately that is the process um
you may have inspired me to submit a
bill to change the process but I think
we're kind of stuck with what we've got
right now but I I I just think it's a
flawed process in a lot of different
ways and um I mean I've only been to one
meeting but um I've already seen things
that concern me but I think is a very
good point the same point we are where
we are um there are a lot of people with
anxiety disorder right now that would
like access to this therapy and I think
that this is unfortunately the only way
to get them we actually have already
approved it for post-traumatic distress
disorder which actually is an anxiety
related disorder as well so that's
already included um I'm a little shocked
that this wasn't one of the first
indications way back
when representative Lon and then
representative Weber uh thank you Mr
chairman we did pass the we passed the
more encompassing Bill however it's not
yet signed into law and the question is
whether or not it will be um there's
another one that hopefully uh comes out
of the house so that people wouldn't
necessarily even need to have an anxiety
recommendation for somebody to walk over
to a store and purchase some if they
just wanted to do that and an anxiety
situation that that may be an
appropriate approach too but until
either or both of those laws be uh bills
becomes law I think that it's really
important to move forward on anxiety
because you know you look at benzo dioa
pans you look at some of the other stuff
used to treat anxiety I think that
adding cannabis to that potential range
of options is is a good idea um it may
not be right for everybody but neither
are benzos neither are other options and
neither are the people for their medical
Martini so I I think this is um
hopefully hopefully we won't need to do
all of these in the future but let's get
this one done today representative Weber
and then representative
Merchant uh I think representative Leon
said pretty much what I was going to say
uh it would be nice to have a better
procedure and we ought to work on that
but until we get one this is something
that there is some evidence that it is
helpful it is much more benign than some
of the other treatments and so I think
we ought to make sure that there is a
vehicle that authorizes it that stays
alive representative
Merchant I want to follow up on
representative Murphy's
uh
comment is it possible to go back to
this bill and look at adding eight that
basically says or any other
disorder authorized by the Cannabis
oversight committee and give them
rulemaking Authority and they get
ourselves out of this representative we
did you have a response for that well I
kind of it's It's partly a response and
it's partly
history the reason that the bill is the
way it is is it was the only way we
could get it passed it was the only way
we could get the governor's sign it and
we have been as greater knowledge occurs
and as greater experience occurs and as
people get less scared of all of this
we've been broadening things uh I don't
think now is the time to start trying to
shoehorn other things in I think what we
ought to do is see where we end up at
the end of this year and then because
you know the the landscape may be very
different in June than it is now and
then I think we ought to try and come up
with something more comprehensive and
considered that that we've looked at
really carefully and with the in uh
input from the commission and and that
may be the way we go but I think that
right now what's before us is anxiety
disorder and as uncomfortable as I am
and I am keeping on adding things in I
think that the approach that we adopted
was to have the commission evaluate what
might be useful and what might be
harmful and to take that into account in
making our decisions so I I'd like to
keep that for now until we know where
we're at representative Murphy and then
representative Nagel thank you it's just
a a plea to uh representative Nagel uh
that I would vote for this bill no no
question about it general anxiety
disorder is an appropriate indication
for the use of U therapeutic cannabis I
just want us to be prepared because my
concern is a more broad issue going
forward we ought to be prepared for uh
the next year having long CO as one of
the indications for
cannabis keep
growing um I I I don't I I personally
think that based on my exper I mean it's
not that I haven't involved in this
commission I've just been to one meeting
but I've been very aware of it for a
long time and I think having um some
oversight of it has a lot of value
personally the other statement I don't
want to leave unchallenged is we we look
at cannabis like it's this trivial drug
it is most definitely not it creates a
lot of problems it ruins a lot of
people's lives it is the gateway drug
according to people at office of
restorative justice for a number of
other drug addictions and I think we
need to be really cautious about how we
proceed with this
discussion uh representative Shar pero
you just put your microphone on do you
have a comment oh no okay any other
discussion I'm seeing none okay motion
is ought to pass on 1349
FN representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative copal yes
representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative poov
yes representative Weber
yes representative M Kay
yeah representative freedus
representative hacken Phillips
yes representative Nutter
upam representative Shiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes representive tez
yes and representative McDonald
yes 190 and one not voting the move
consent is consent acceptable being a
oh is there any money attached I mean
okay all
right there's no objection yeah we'll
consent okay next up is HB 1350
representative mlan I think that's yours
you up yes Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion of ought to pass on HB
1350 there second second would you like
to speak to your motion representative
McLean yeah I I think this is a this is
a pretty straightforward Bill
the uh oh yeah that's right okay sorry
sorry I'm retreating I didn't know we
had bills like that famous last
words the the TCM o um unanimously was
in support of this bill what it does is
it moves moves the the amount that can
be spens dispensed from the ATC from 2 O
up to 4 ounces in in a 10-day period
which is I I think a modest increase um
it's it's my understanding that we the
amount of atcs we have in the state is
only like four or five so for people in
rural communities I think that creates a
big burden maybe it might drive them to
go look elsewhere I really don't want to
to have that happen so I think this is a
modest proposal as I said
um unanimous support from the TCM o um
so I hope everybody will support it
thank you other discussion
representative Merchant I support it as
well I think I'd rather see this come to
the point of having more locations
available versus having people to go a
long distance regardless of the amount
of um cannabis um but unfortunately
that's not the bill before Force the
bill before force is to allow for a
greater amount to be taken at one time
but I would like to see a bill somewhere
along the way to revise the THC
location so patients don't have to
travel in the first
place other
discussion seeing none motion is ought
to pass on 1350
FN representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative copal yes representative
CA yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes
yes representative pza yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative
fedus representative hackin Phillips
yes representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative
Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ
yes those
yes yes okay representative McDonald
yes 19 to zero and one not voting
andent U there's no
objection Mr chair can I make a
suggestion going forward could we
possibly take up 1609 FN next because I
think that that one's likely to be
less fraud easy given the fact we have
eight minutes
left I think we can try and get both of
them done in that time you'll be
surprised well why don't we do 1609 and
then if we can get the 1482 then all
right so our next up is 169 FN I have a
motion Mr chairman I have a motion for
an amendment okay by 1609 okay and the
amendment is passed out already it
should be at your seat I move that we
0755 okay uh would you like U
representative Murphy seconds
representative pushman do you want to
speak to your motion yes thank you uh as
discussed during the hearing uh there is
no representation on the uh membership
of the interdisciplinary Primary Care
Workforce Commission and uh it was
recommended that we amend and I did
speak um with
remind me her
name Dr
Murphy
Mary yes and um she was okay with adding
them in and having them a part of the
conversation there too uh so I put in an
amendment to add a direct primary care
provider appointed by the New England
direct Primary Care
Alliance
okay any
discussion on this amendment
I'm assuming that it's the case although
it's although it's the New England
Direct Care primary Alliance do we
assume that they're appointing a New
Hampshire
provider they have providers in New
Hampshire it's not specified that it
will be a New Hampshire
provider um but I'm not sure if all of
the members on the board are necessarily
residents of New Hampshire
anyway
England representative
Murphy um I don't have a problem with it
being specified one way or the other um
as we'll see going forward um there
going to be a number of alternative
payment you know um methodologies coming
forward and they'll be both regionally
Statewide and nationally um run so for
instance and I was I mentioned this
before to representative kushman last
night or this morning driving in i'
listen to the radio and you may not know
it yet but Amazon Prime is now going to
come out with a primary care uh package
as well offering primary care and it may
start off as mostly tele medicines but I
think what we're going to see going
forward is that we're going to have a
number of um not just local but
regionally and nationally these type of
organizations that will be um uh getting
into the primary care market and so if
they if New England direct Prim care is
the one that appoints it um it would it
would be fine more than likely it would
have to be New Hampshire only because
Primary Care is going to be local and
you want to have you know you don't want
to have a primary care in Rhode Island
and have somebody from um Co County in
represent of Kings area drive all the
way down there so it would probably um
by the nature of primary here be more
close local to their constituents or
their
patients other discussion representative
kushman just wanted to add there's no
New Hampshire specific Organization for
direct Primary Care Providers they they
all belong to the New England um
Alliance other
discussion seeing none the motion is out
0755 representa lean yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative copel yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel represent poo yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay yeah
representative
fedus representative hecken Phillips
yes represent nut upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes represent
Palmer yes representative TZ yes and
represent McDonald yes 19 Z and one not
voting okay do I have another motion
is there a second representative kushman
seconds any
discussion seeing none the clerk is
ready representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Copo
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel
yes representative poo yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative
fedus representative hacken Phillips yes
representative nut upam yes representa
representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ yes and representative McDonald
voting yeah I was there money involved
in this one they could give us a fiscal
impact at the time I got the bill anyway
so I have no there's no objection we'll
put that on consent for it all right now
I know some people have a hard stop of 3
o'
least it's okay with everybody else it's
certainly okay with me uh next up is HB
1482 representative Seth King I'd like
to make a motion of itl and House Bill
1482 is there a second second uh okay
representative vetta upam
seconded
okay okay uh would you like to speak to
your motion yeah I just want to say that
um while I am a supporter of the general
idea of bringing a Marketplace involved
for the sale of blood and organs um this
bill is so poorly crafted that I don't
think we should be wasting any time
debating the merits of that I hope that
next year the sponsor or somebody else
will bring forward a bill that we can
really that those of us who support the
idea can really get behind and then
we'll but for this year I think it
should just be put to rest
representative palaza uh well I
understand I will be in absolute
minority I think it should be out to
pass this bill is an important step to
solve the shortage of blood and organs
and it's all immoral situation when our
heroic donors are not only fairly
compensated but sometimes they are
punished for example uh they have to pay
pay for their recovery and sometimes uh
their life insurance is in danger from
Their donation we are being told by
lobbyists that current system is working
and moral uh but last year you remember
we heard the same but uh only to learn
that uh federal government itself is
trying uh to fix it by breaking the
United Network for sharing organs Yus
multi- deade Monopoly because the
situation is so dire and broken uh so we
currently allow to sell plasma and other
organs uh so this bill will help to save
lives thank you other
discussion seeing none motion is itl on
House Bill 1482 Mr Park representative
Lon yes representative krishman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
yes representative McKay
yeah representative
fedus vote uh representative hackam
Phillips yes
representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative taes yes and
representative McDonald
yes okay it's
181 and one not voting repres
representative paza I assume no Minority
Report or yes he's ready oh is okay all
right I need that by tomorrow morning
okay again anybody who owes me a report
if you can't get it into me today please
morning he he's doing Minority Report so
thank you everyone we did it I wasn't
sure we would but we did it thank you
everybody and I'll see you tomorrow we
Jour
yeah
e